en passant par le speechess ou les title
Tuesday
chase.com/avent secours tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream salut à toi Antoine j'espère que
tu vas bien que tu as passé une très
bonne soirée hier aujourd'hui on reprend
avec la ronde 2 du Nord white chef salut
stuff et salut tout le monde
effectivement on devrait avoir une très
très belle ronde encore aujourd'hui hier
on a vu le numéro 1 mondial et le numéro
2 mondial tombé tous les deux c'est
quand même assez rare à voir sur une
seule journée d'échec je pense pas qu'on
aura autant de surprises aujourd'hui
mais on a quand même de très très beaux
combats en perspective alors les
appareils j'ai voulu vous les mettre sur
l'urbes mais apparemment cheescom a pas
mis les bons appariements donc je vais
vous les donner moi-même d'ailleurs donc
ces appareils non alors on va avoir avec
les Blancs Magnus Carson il est un peu
revanchard de sa partie d'hier contre
carvana qui ont les blancs cette fois-ci
contre Wesley Sow
ceux qui nous a bien surpris hier dans
sa partie contre Nakamura
Antoine
donc je te redirai après la dictée des
appareils donc on va voir table 2 on va
voir un Taris avec les Blancs contre
abdos torov donc je te propose je te
propose Stéphane qu'on fasse un
pronostic pour chaque partie je crois
qu'on a le même mais
si tu veux je peux changer je peux
changer les pronostics pour toi moi je
parie nul pour la première
allez moi je pars
je vais essayer de changer d'accord tu
varie tu varies
et la deuxième donc on a
Ariane Tariq a fait une bonne entrée en
matière hier contre ma mère et qui
affronte le crack-up d'où ça torov là
moi je vois bien une victoire d'Abdou
ben écoute moi aussi mais du coup je
vais mettre nul tu es pas obligé tu es
pas obligé de faire différent de moi à
chaque fois
alors que les parties vont commencer oui
ça s'avance peu on va avoir ensuite
tu en penses toi
allez petite pièce sur la nul parce que
tu as qu'à être très très solide avec
les noirs
je suis obligé de parler pour Google
je verrais bien une nulle également mais
ils peuvent nous offrir un combat très
très long et très très
profonds c'était guéri qu'il avait
emporté sur kanwana donc bon je vais
quand même mettre nul là je vais te
parler
[Musique]
un podium un podium
passer 2800
mondial une place qu'il a quasiment plus
quitté depuis donc bah écoute moi je
vais mettre une petite nulle sur sur
Paris
alors les parties que j'ai commencé à
17h02
et la partie qui vont commencer dans un
instant alors on voit la main voilà de
d'un officiel je sais pas qui c'était
qui a joué le premier coup de Magnus T4
partie
savoir
je pense qu'il y a eu il y a eu serrage
de main là et le pion 4 qui a l'air de
rester en place ouais ça écrit sur les
feuilles
E4 c'est le premier coup de cette partie
on va pas encore mais on va le voir
bientôt
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va pas sur mon
échiquier on devrait le voir normalement
sur le chéquier
ce serait préférable en effet je vais
essayer de
Thierry fraîche peut-être mais ah ça y
est on voit E4 et on voit ce qui a
triché qui a 22 heures 12 à la pendule
on est là pour un bout de temps
mais ça va être ça va être remis en
place donc je vous rappelle la cadence
la cadence c'est deux heures 40 2h ko
pardon jusqu'au 40e coup et au 40e coup
les joueurs auront 10 secondes par coup
pas d'incréments supplémentaire pas de
rajoutant en minutes juste 10 secondes
parcours
aussi ce qui va se passer c'est que en
cas d'égalité et ben il y aura
l'Armageddon donc l'Armageddon ou les
blancs auront
10 minutes avec obsession gagner et donc
auront 7 mais si les noirs sont nuls non
c'est l'inverse
c'est le contraire c'est noir les Noirs
ont moins de temps ils ont 7 minutes et
si l'emporte s'il l'emporte il gagne le
2600 nul ils font ils gagne le demi
point aussi donc
uniquement c'est ça et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs Antoine et ben hier on se
demandait parce que moi je voyais un
petit peu c'est pendant l'armée
notamment de de so Wesley contre
Nakamura les joueurs avec 5 secondes
chacun et tu voyais qui il veut des
coups il jouait très très vite et tu
voyais vraiment que le temps s'écoulait
pas et en fait la cadence exacte du
de l'Armageddon c'est 7 minutes
pour les Noirs entre 10 minutes pour les
blancs
et passer 40ème coup les deux joueurs
ont une seconde d'incabre d'accord et ça
on ne savait pas hier on pensait que
c'est du flag et on a on les a vu jouer
on a vu ceux qui a fini les derniers
coups debout et on pensait que c'était
du chaos mais en fait ça n'était pas
alors pour un faux pour les gens qui
jouent pas trop en réel une seconde
d'incrément ça suffit pas vraiment ça a
continué à jouer on finit quand même pas
tomber avec une seconde d'incrément
puisque physiquement prendre la pièce la
bouger appuyer sur la pendule ça peut
prendre plus d'une seconde si elle a
l'autre bout de l'échiquier par exemple
c'est ça
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a vu deux
joueurs très agités à la fin ils étaient
quasiment debout en train de jouer leur
coup n'a qu'à se nique quand même pas
tomber ce qui est rare et pour revenir
tout de suite à la partie de l'espagnol
que sont en train de jouer au bac de
scarsen et Wesley Sow on a vu que Magnus
a refusé les velléités de berlinoise en
fait il a fait la l'espagnol d'échange
tout de suite
donc voilà faut prendre ceci directement
des Français 6 bon c'est pas vraiment
l'espagnol d'échange
mais il a fait des trois en premier
voilà et prends C6 donc en fait c'est ça
la mode c'est position c'est assez la
mode et les blancs ici et c'est
l'obtenir un avantage donc le lieu des
blancs en fait ça va être un jeu sur
case noire ici avec leur fou bien sûr et
les Blancs jouent sur le fait que ils
ont prioré la position la structure
depuis on est noir donc un plan ici pour
les noirs on va sûrement un petit roc
suivi de d'un plan avec cavalier 17 et
F6 rond souvent un truc comme ça pour
essayer de bien maintenir le centre donc
peut-être que d'abord on va commencer
par cavaler des 7 il me semble aussi est
un coup
je suis pas un grand spécialiste mais
généralement ces positions on va jouer
avec les 7 alors je sais pas dans quel
ordre voilà il a joué
et ici actuellement il y a plusieurs
idées
à avoir donc rapidement F4 il peut
arriver bon il y a un fond en 5 ici
comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici
est-ce que cavaler des deux cavalier B3
streaming
C3
B4 D4
j'imagine que tout ça sont des idées
tout à fait viables le parcours du
cavalier cavale des deux cavalet F1
Caval G3 peut être tout à fait viable
aussi
en fait ce qui est bien c'est que Magnus
choisi de de refuser la grande ligne
berlinoises pour avoir une partie où on
garde les dames longtemps et essayer de
jouer pour un avantage donc ça c'est
intéressant
[Musique]
et très solide pour les blancs et pour
les noirs et puis maintenant je pense
qu'il essaie juste de l'avoir
[Musique]
et bonjour à tous Dans le chat on voit
caillou el marlou on voit Yuma le petit
prince on va créer des windsdom bonjour
à tous j'espère que vous allez bien
merci de nous suivre
et à mon avis sur la Catalane ben c'est
une ouverture qui est très bonne qui est
extrêmement solide et pour te dire la
vérité
j'ai un petit peu arrêté la slave pour
ça aussi tu vois je les déteste la jouer
contre la Catalane parce que j'ai
l'impression que les Blancs ont toujours
un joueur Monieux
et donc voilà je suis pas fan du tout
côté noir mais après aussi c'est pas une
potion que j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans
la vie
donc c'est aussi peut-être
assez désagréable de jouer contre la
Catalane face à un face à un adversaire
bien préparé et s'allume à l'équipe
est-ce que ça te dirait d'aller voir la
partie de la resa contre contre charia
moviejarov allez
le fantasme caseri a accepté le gambidam
du français ok alors attendez je vous
mets les parties ils doivent être ici
voilà
alors oui donc ça c'est aussi des
positions qui sont ils sont assez la
mode en ce moment
des cadets la prise E4 alors le 4
généralement c'est
[Musique]
pardon c'est pas le coup on va dire plus
simple
pour récupérer ton C4 c'est plus risqué
et ça joue plus pour l'initiative
j'imagine de mettre les deux pions au
centre dès le début donc le 5 est normal
donc cavalier F3
donc là c'est une position qui est hyper
théorique on imagine il y a aussi B5 qui
a été joué ici pour défendre l'option C4
computant du fait que le cavalier blanc
soit cloué et que du coup qu'elle est
convaincre pas possible
F3 petit rock et on avait une partie
comme ça
récemment c'était Guiri avec les Noirs
contre
je me rappelle pas mais
je crois bien que c'était
est-ce que c'est pas un forest
bref j'ai vu cette position j'ai déjà vu
quelque part à trois
il me semble que c'était un gris bonne
forêt mais je me trompe peut-être alors
je me pose une question dans cette dans
la position juste avant après à trois
que se passait-il sur fou D6 qu'est-ce
qu'on faisait son qu'est-ce qu'on
faisait de ce cavalier sur le foot S6
alors vous décis
déjà il faut se poser la question parce
qu'il se passe si je mange le pion parce
qu'à la base B5 a été joué parce que le
cavalier était cloué ouais c'est vrai
que
il faut voir parce qu'il y a des
peut-être des complications regarde là
j'ai une idée j'ai une idée mais bon en
vrai c'est on va voir la jauge je pense
qu'il va qui va descendre très très vite
salut robinside regardez bien tu arrives
au bon moment pour la démonstration
qu'elle va dépendre des 5 je pensais
je pensais à ça
la jauge ou elle bouge même pas
incroyable qui n'a pas trembler
incroyable
bon si tu prends là je pourrai prendre
du cavalier même du pion est intéressant
et pourquoi est-ce que chaque client
cavalier pour ouvrir ma
dame ici hier
je profite de cet établissement pour
emmener madame ils sont reprises là je
sais pas encore si c'est pas mes chèques
si je faisais pour prendre avant ici je
pense que je préfère ça et là j'ai deux
fois
ah non moi j'ai qu'un cheval
ça commence on a que 10 minutes de
stream mais non
4 ça commence à être très grave mais
voyez il y a une pièce de plus pour les
blancs mais là c'est chaud par exemple
où les chats d'un point 4 échec attaque
la tourmatique et si je bouge le roi bah
enfin je vais vous quoi ça il y a ton D8
si je vais là il y a encore ça c'est
chaud c'est chaud c'est très chaud après
pour voir je sais pas
mais intéressant en tout cas
[Musique]
les lignes farfelues qui commencent à
pleuvoir c'est pas du tout pas c'est ça
dans la partie puisqu'il a envoyé tout
de suite voilà 4 sur X5 donc en fait il
laisse il laisse le fou revenir en B4
mais les Noirs ont pas le temps il faut
d'abord protéger ce pion B5 donc il le
faut et d'ailleurs alors si elle bleu
salut j'espère que tu vas bien ciel bleu
c'est le mot spécialiste de statistiques
etc sur le chat
j'ai vu cette partie je sais plus quand
il y a pas longtemps je me demande si
c'était pas le le tata style que j'ai
commenté
une partie il me semble ah non ça y est
je me souviens
tu étais avec les Noirs ventes Forest et
les blancs c'était l'Iranien
[Musique]
contre
nul et ben forest il a vachement
souffert en cette partie je suis sûr à
100% peut-être partie a été joué voilà
par un matelot contre vente forest au
tata style 2022
alors est-ce qu'on peut regarder
pourquoi tactiquement ça marchait pas de
faire B4 au lieu d'assis parce que
Kavala 2 j'imagine en B4
alors
parce que tu vois que même si je prends
en cavalière voilà tu as encore C5 et tu
attaques à la fois là et à la fois là et
en fait
j'ai encore qu'à aller prendre un 4
pardon et dans
une pluie de contre jeu
pour les Noirs ça m'a l'air assez
monstrueux c'était pas si inintéressant
cette idée bécane
une approche plus sûre avec simplement à
6 mais là il pourrait commencer à y
avoir des
en fait
je pense que là concrètement ce plan il
va être perdu
[Musique]
en faisant cavalier à deux ou cavaler
bien
ce plan il va être perdu en fait sur le
long terme et que je pourrais le
capturer par exemple si je fais ça
après sortir mes pièces ok
mais
tu vois sur B3 échec je pense à cavaler
cette fois
mais bon c'est pas pas clair
mais je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeux peut-être cavaliers 5
le pion C4 il va tomber de toute façon
après le B1 c'est sûr mais qu'est-ce que
en fait je regarde bien
et là quand même non
peut-être que voilà là je pense comme ça
peut-être que maintenant en fait le
problème
la chose qui bouge pas tout à fait c'est
pour laquelle ce dommage 4 et maintenant
il part intéressant sur cette page je
prends la tour sur voilà bon j'ai pas
fougère comme j'ai raté
mais j'ai au moins échec là et je
ramasse un paquet de pions et tu as rien
sorti quoi regarde tes pièces et c'est
pour ça qu'on dit au débutant souvent de
pas bouger le pion F en début de partie
et surtout tant qu'ils ont pas ok
évidemment
et là effectivement il y avait cette
ressource tactique pour les noirs
[Musique]
attends parce qu'elle appartient
je suis sûr que c'est la même
ou alors c'est très semblant
si tu peux me chercher ça
demander trop je suis quasium cette
position exacte et le super bête je l'ai
pas du tout regardé j'étais assez occupé
j'ai quasiment pas suivi
le superbe qu'est-ce que tu préfères une
Nimes au complexe une tarage ou une une
Sicilienne avec fou B5 on va aller on va
aller tout voir
sans te dire lesquels qui sont les
joueurs
c'est le joueur local en plus avec
Marius carzen donc le joueur local qui
est ici qui allait blanc et contre le
jeune
qui a perdu hier à marmageddon contre
anis
si vous voulez il a envoyé un Gambie
assez qu'on voit assez souvent dans les
siciliennes mais plutôt ouvertes
donc là avec tout de suite
a fait le travail il revient en F1 et on
se développe comme une dizaine fermée et
la boum B4 ok alors on va essayer
d'expliquer un peu tout ce qui s'est
passé là
je vais essayer de vous expliquer un peu
tout ça alors ce dimanche je la joue
beaucoup donc je connais pas mal ces
idées là
je sais que
pour j'évite bon c'est un coup que je ne
connaissais pas mais je sais qu'il y a
un coup qui est qui est assez connu
aussi c'est l'idée avec G5
[Musique]
mais alors que dire de l'idée H5 G4 H5
ici alors
bien sûr
je calcule jamais de ligne en direct
c'est toujours long terme ouais alors
oui mais le problème c'est que tu as pas
entendu des pièces il y a un visa vilain
et moi je risque de tout ouvrir donc
c'est pas encore comment peut-être des
quatre d'ailleurs
je peux manger là je pense là
il a pas d'abris quand on rentre ça va
pas être possible petit rock ça va être
chaud et au centre ben écoute je suis un
nouvel au centre donc
visuellement ça m'a l'air dégueulasse
mais après il faut voir concrètement tu
vois sur du h sur le G4 plus tard j'ai
peut-être du h30 du H4
mais là tu vois Abdou après son tour G8
il a passé il a pas fait G5 tout de
suite il a commencé par acheter parce
que moi je lis le commentaire de ciel
bleu ah je suis content j'étais sûr de
moi tu vois mars
comme fr euh cette partie ils viennent
de dévier d'ailleurs
c'est plus que c'était puis finalement
je me suis rappelé de Maxou de l'eau qui
a fait ça a fait nul mais avec les
Blancs il avait un bel avantage et il a
un peu il avait sacrifié une pièce pour
une marée de pions c'est une super
partie max mais maintenant qui a pas
réussi à terminer mais c'est une partie
monstrueuse bref
donc voilà je pense que c'est simple
naturel c'est un coup qui existe déjà vu
et en fait comme un sport avec les
jouets bah pas par le 5 dans le désert
parce qu'il y a quand même pas mal
besoin de
de préparation pour réussir à faire G4
au final et donc en fait tout rouge de 8
qui va l'aider à préparer je suis à 4 on
retourne
c'est un coup j'ai envie de dire qui est
un peu surprenant généralement
[Musique]
il a montré son intention mais ça
annonce une partie de dingue parce que
là tout de suite sur tour G8 bon tari a
fait son petit détroit qui est logique
il a pas du tout envie de d'ouvrir le
centre encore et juste après il a envoyé
B4 parce qu'il se dit maintenant ok le
roi noir il va sans doute pas ok
j'arrive de s'occuper de la grande
diagonale il veut prendre très très
grande diagonale avec son foot case noir
je pense
donc il a envoyé B4 fut A3 sacrifice
d'option c'est hyper intéressant en fait
quand on voit ça le concept des blancs
il est très intéressant là moi j'aurais
fait des cartes perso ça m'énerve pas
logique
mais peut-être plutôt des cadres je
pense ouvrir la position à l'art quand
même assez logique
pour empêcher
j'ai 5 la H6 a été joué donc bon
clairement il avait 5 je crois qu'on a
compris et ici après H6 et ben Ici Paris
a joué le super coup un B4 alors B4
cette position toujours pas comme ça au
hasard et si je vous tempo si je vais
tempo donc c'est clair que tu arrives il
connaît la position et c'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour Abdou
parce que c'est que cette ligne a l'air
quand même très bizarre pour les noirs
et je me dis que si c'est une position
très bizarre et que tu arrives en face
et ben il arrive et qu'il est préparé
sur la position et ben ça reste
difficile pour les noirs
mais après B4 alors plusieurs choses
mais c'est clairement ce qu'on va faire
c'est ouvrir la case noire
et en plus on sait que les Noirs vont
pas réussir à regrets donc on a vraiment
envie de voir la position donc ça paraît
logique qu'elle va les prendre B4 je me
poses la question savoir est-ce que je
enfin qu'est-ce que je joue ici parce
que
j'imagine que c'est pour pour
essayer de profiter du fait que le
cavalier soit pas là
pour faire un truc ailleurs je pensais
c'est ça ouvre la position directe sur
le roi
je sais pas la suite
mais admettons que je joue un coup en
barre du style tous les deux
en fait la question c'est comment est-ce
que tu joues
avec les Noirs parce que tu as du mal à
bouger des pièces et ton G5 il ressemble
plus à grand chose parce que tes pièces
n'ont pas actives et j'ai plus mon
cavalier 3 pour que la rupture en G4
j'ai l'impression que c'est une réaction
assez forte de la part des blancs il
sacrifie un pion pour pouvoir le jeu
immédiatement les blancs qui veulent
punir un petit peu le
le non développement on va dire des
pièces noires jusqu'à H3 à 6 on était
dans une ligne qui était quand même
assez jouée et là bon faut F1 c'est un
coup ultra thématique dans cette
ouverture le tour G8 par contre à cet
endroit là de Tours J8 7 tours G8 c'est
une nouveauté d'après la base là que
j'ai sous les yeux
existent mais tour G8 n'a jamais été
joué et tari a réfléchi 2 minutes à
faire des trois et sur h6 il a joué
tempo B4 A3 il s'est dit en fait en 2
minutes il a réfléchi 2 minutes sur le
Tour G8 et il s'est dit je vais faire un
Gambie de l'aile avec B4 non mais là tu
arrives il va pas sacrifier un pion au
bout de 10 coups s'il connaît pas la
pollution
à trois systématique l'idée c'est qu'il
veut vraiment
ouvrir les cases noires
et après 10 minutes de réflexion
finalement
Abdou a poussé son G5 il l'a fait son G5
donc là il y a eu sur A3 il y a eu B3 il
veut rendre le pion tout en fermant le
CASE noir et sur C4 il a fait G5
donc bah écoute position chaude hein
il a récupéré son pion sacrifié donc
c'était pas vraiment un sacrifice il a
été refusé par par Abdou sa torov et G4
qui part ah je prends G4 cavaliers G4
c'était c'était cool de fil blanc c'est
en train de se passer l'ouverture de la
colonne h est-ce qu'elle fait peur parce
que moi ça me fait un peu peur pour les
blancs ouais bah alors contrat d'où je
serai pas forcément serein dire que bon
bah il y a une tour sur mon roi et la
colonne h est ouverte arrête pas de
pions en tout cas mais d'un autre côté
on voit que j'ai l'avantage au centre et
aussi de développement donc
voilà donc après on le dit un DAB 56
donc ça devient salut Mick du 44800
bonjour à toi
et DAF du 56 je pense aussi par stock
fish donc c'est pas une grosse truie non
plus en fait
l'idée c'est que
[Musique]
c'est super stock fish mais les gens
sont pas stop fish tu vois et bien sûr
la préparation d'ouverture fait que les
joueurs connaissent beaucoup de choses
et on travaille tout ça avec
l'ordinateur donc c'est vrai que c'est
un peu normal qu'on arrive à une
position un peu complètement folle et
que les deux joueurs suivent la théorie
enfin suivent stock fish parce que
maintenant c'est le moyen c'est le
meilleur moyen de travailler un stop
fiche à haut niveau les joueurs c'est
comme ça prouve les nouveautés et les
meilleures variantes etc
mais après de là à ce que Paris soit
préparés aussi bien sur une variante qui
n'a jamais été joué je trouve ça où oui
c'est complètement dingue et surtout
ne dire Beck là il a quand même réfléchi
10 minutes 10 minutes c'est pas du bluff
là ils savent pas ils savent pas où ils
sont là donc il suce
et après peut-être qu'il
c'est possible que ils ont un petit peu
le choix dans la variante encore une
fois je pense pas que ce soit des
joueurs qui vont déballer tempo
l'embryante ils ont besoin un petit peu
de vérifier d'être sur deux etc et
voilà ils ont une idée générale de la
position c'est sûr mais je pense pas
alors c'est je me trompe mais je pense
pas qu'ils avaient cette position ce
matin sur leurs ordinateur d'analyse
alors les blancs c'est sûr que non les
blancs
mais bon c'est l'impression qu'il a déjà
vu voilà et après B400 tu peux nous en
préparation de cadre parce que c'est
quand même thématique dans la religion
le b43 ça reste hyper thématique
par contre le jeu aussi vite
enfin genre aussi fort etc voilà c'est
sûr que c'est lui tout ça mélangé c'est
pas enfin ça sort pas de n'importe après
il faut il faut aussi admettre que c'est
joueurs ont une mémoire exceptionnelle
et qu'il est possible que tu arrives et
bosser cette ligne au pif il y a deux
mois ça me dit quelque chose j'avais une
idée de mes quatre à cinq il a vérifié
deux minutes ouais c'est bon c'est ça ça
marche surtout avec une position tout à
fait jouable non c'est possible mais
mais B4 tu peux jouer 25 coups que tu
peux le savoir mais là aussi vite je
pense que non je pense que il connaît il
a déjà position et Abdou est-ce que
s'attendait à B4
je pense pas forcément parce que c'est
vrai qu'encore une fois je pense que des
quatre
à la place de Détroit ici moi en tout
cas m'a l'air hyper naturel
tu prends je prends
et là c'est une sorte de
6 une sorte de chevelingue
avec pour Angélique bon je suis pas un
spécialiste de la cheveningue elle a
l'air bête tatouage vite quand même
après
au centre des fois il y a du même des
idées il faut pas être si le on fait je
vais prendre le 7 ça fait thématique
donc bon bah pour les bien placé si on
fait ça mais écoute là j'ai mon fond F1
qui normalement n'est pas en F1 j'ai mon
fond ancien normalement il est en J5 un
peu différent mais en terme de structure
moi je j'adore les blancs ici je me dis
mais attends je vais t'ouvrir quoi
et j'ai l'impression que les blancs sont
déjà hyper bien quoi mais bon je ne sais
pas il y a des trois B4 clairement
clairement Paris il avait
il avait une il avait l'idée donc en
tout cas on va voir une partie il va
falloir là
tout de suite il y a
il y a un pion en prise il est
certainement pas prenable j'ai
l'impression que la dame je parle du
pion B7 bien sûr j'ai l'impression
qu'après tour B8 la dame doit pas être
en étant fermée
ouais non c'est pas trop ce qu'il
cherche à faire même ce serait trop non
ça renferme regarde
ma 6 tourbé 6
et d'Ama 4 seule case
il va y avoir des cavalles des 4 et
Caval F3 et des découvertes aussi ouais
non non mais ça a l'air dégueu
il va pas aller les prendre là
clairement
comme E5 serait pas tout à fait débile
et pourquoi pas de T4 alors soit un
petit peu long mais
voilà c'est quoi la menace des Noirs là
il y avait pas vraiment encore de
menaces il menace de menacer un jour
mais je pense son plan ça va risque
d'être un moment donné aussi être amené
la dame
ouais
pièces et pour fur et à mesure là
peut-être alors eux 6 cavalent 5
et 6 le cavalier ici et changer une
paire de cavalier mettre l'autre là
ramenez la dame un peu par là une fois
que le Caval a été changé je pourrais H4
mais du coup avec les Blancs j'ai envie
d'attaquer j'ai envie d'ouvrir et là je
pense à E5
je sais pas mais
c'est trop en fait c'est peut-être ça va
pas en fait mais je me dis que je peux
faire des quatre et vite ouvrir
immédiatement parce que là je menace de
faire un peu plus méchant non
ça dépend de préparer un autre chose
je vais ouvrir la colonne je vais mettre
un fou peut-être en F4 je vais
développer mon cavalan C3 mettre une
dame une dame
j'ai cavalué 5 sur E5 là
alors évidemment c'est dommage d'avoir
fait des trois dans la pose puis des
quatre trois tours trois coups plus tard
je le regarde c'est d'ouvrir un peu la
position et d'avoir un contact rapide
mais c'est pas évident parce que bon il
faut aussi que je sorte les pièces quoi
et un petit coup de cavalier c'est trois
ça peut pas être mauvais
fondamentalement à moins que ce soit
dans la position
et peut-être par exemple je sais pas
comment je joue mais je pensais à un
truc comme ça
j'ai regardé l'ordinateur pour vérifier
il propose de D4 meilleures
dans lequel tu croyais le plus
ok ok ok bon
[Musique]
alors
non mais je sais de raisonner un peu par
logique sachant que c'est un peu une
course au roi et que on revrait la
colonne mais bon je peux pas ouvrir
ouais pour ouvrir peut-être des quatre
d'abord me semblait assez logique
alors faire attention à un thème
tactique que je viens en tête de voir
imaginons si je fais un truc comme
cavale C3 et que je fais aussi
et ben une idée tactique que je pourrais
avoir je passe ça marche
ça va
F3 donc là je peux calculer
ça va trop loin mais j'ai dit que c'est
chaud et la barre elle aime beaucoup les
5 pour mater
[Musique]
mais j'ai pas encore trouvé le cool
on va faire
ramener une pièce
[Musique]
on était trop trop loin dans notre
cœur là mais en fait bah écoute donc ça
c'est un thème aussi d'un distraction
qui va essayer de dévier ce cavalier
pour venir mon H4 est maté H2 et aussi
ajouter donc faut pas oublier ce thème
souvent la tour elle est en F1 et défend
je pense pas la question de la marche 4
avec un fou en F1 et ben on peut
toujours faire attention à ce genre de
choses et salut à ceux qui viennent de
nous rejoindre il y a du DAF du 56 il y
a Proudhon Cécile 18 salut tout le monde
salut à tous
on se régale devant la deuxième ronde du
Norway de chasse en direct de Stavenger
en Norvège et on était sur la partie
donc entre le jeune local argentary et
nos diabète
et on pourrait passer continuer autour
des stats peut-être est-ce que tu veux
aller voir
je sais que c'est ton petit préféré ton
petit ton petit protégé de ma radio
goûtesh c'est ça et oui on avait joué
ensemble en équipe un top 12 et depuis
je le suis dans chaque tournoi et
il a gagné hier il a battu bon les
relations aux gens alors là est-ce que
tu étais plus fort que lui à l'époque où
tu jouais en Top 12 avec
la question
il avait 13 ans il était grand maître il
avait 25 ans
avec
d'ailleurs Prague je crois qu'il a
d'ailleurs
ah oui c'était lui le plus jeune à
l'époque il a fait le deuxième plus
jeune oui c'est ça
donc il nous a fait une t'arrache
Nakamura avec voilà on a on a un pur
isolé qui est un pion isolé que que tu
détestes j'aime pas ouais mais bon
ça reste totalement ok donc Nakamura
style quand même assez solide
calcul hiver vient bon tout le monde
connaît Nakamura
tous les temps et Hikaru donc
celui qu'on appelle le streamer
américain et on a une position qui
ressemble un peu à celle qu'on a vu hier
ensemble quand même un peu à celle qu'on
avait dans la partie avec gris avec les
Noirs
je crois je vois un petit fou G3 H4 G3
un fou de 5 h 4G3 qui pour arriver avec
une tour qui peut venir aussi en C1 sur
la colonne ouverte taquiner la dame en
C7 il y a eu à 4 on se trompe et A4
c'est un coup que j'avais pas
anticipé mais qui est qui a l'air très
intéressant avec l'idée B4
et si on B4 maintenant on a un problème
sur A6 est-ce que ce serait pas ce qu'on
appelle un coût responsable sous bah oui
ça ça c'est un coup qui donne des cases
qui prend des cases aussi un quoi c'est
chaud mais maintenant après Caval de 4
faut voir un peu ce qui se passe mais on
est même pas sûr qu'il aille dans le
cadre d'ailleurs
tu veux le mettre où bah en fait
comme les Noirs font B4 et ben il nous
donne aussi l'accès à des cases
ce serait impossible à cause du piment
de 5 mais quand le client arrive en B4
on se dit tiens à cavalier quand même
souvent il va venir défendre le pion
P4 donc si je mets un cavalier ici je
pourrais attaquer la faiblesse aussi
occuper ou contre la case la case E5 un
jour peut-être qui allait et aussi
construire des cas c'est sympa genre
[Musique]
sa carte et que je mets un fond en G3 et
ben les cases noires un petit peu et
c'est intéressant
ok donc encore une fois je ne sais pas
j'ai pas la jauge elle parle un peu pour
moi mais mais c'est vrai que
attention à pas perdre les quatre
tactiquement sur le chemin quand même il
y aura sûrement des fou B5 en fin de
variante qui font échec et qui
récupérerait la tour après cavale prend
des quatre car elle prend des quatre
tout reprend des quatre fou B5
récupérerait la tour donc ça gagnerait
de qualité
tu n'as pas développé
ouais donc ok ça veut dire
mais voilà ce que je veux dire en fait
c'est que cette idée de mettre le
cavalier en B12 C4 c'est hyper
thématique hyper normal maintenant et
ben écoute je peux aussi aller au Cap
j'ai pas mal de possibilités donc c'est
pas je sais pas vraiment lequel est le
mieux mais là c'est le calcul
il nous le dira en tout cas l'idée de
faire un cadre pour gagner des cases
côté quelque chose d'assez standard et
salut Patou comment ça se passe
j'imagine que pendant 4 c'est même pas
envisageable
[Musique]
en C5 non généralement ça c'est pas trop
recommandé et ne pas toucher ne pas
toucher n'est pas non plus recommandé
puisque sinon on perd un pion tout
simplement il est attaqué deux fois
trois fois il faut je pense qu'il faut
le pousser mais après on va voir là je
pense qu'on est plus ou moins encore
dans peut-être les préparations
d'ouverture encore donc
donc voilà si on n'a pas été voir encore
on n'a pas vu encore guéri contre Aniche
et on a le gars
en vrai souffle qui rit c'est la même
personne effectivement contre le
vainqueur d'hier contre Fabien ocarwana
qui a livré quand même une petite Master
Class hier contre Carl Seine il a été il
a été formidable et on a une Nimzo qui
est super intéressante
depuis le début j'y comprends pas tout
mais alors c'est beau
[Musique]
de prendre la voiture avec moi je te le
confesse
ça c'est
elle comprendra
ou V5 alors ce pion en C5 il va un jour
être perdu
et
mais pour l'instant bah écoute je vais
casses noires en plus
et un jeu assez actif des deux côtés tu
vois comme tout à l'heure un petit peu
quasiment qui sont hyper ouvertes
et avec un pion qui contrôle aussi c'est
quasiment dans la case des 6
donc là on pense bien sûr à bouger la
dame je sais pas trop la mettre
le coup E4 au tout début qui doit être
théorique j'imagine
paraît tellement risqué à cause de Caval
C3
j'imagine qu'il y a quelque chose de
horrible après qu'elle va le C3 sans
doute dame D2 et les deux sûrement je
pense
que le cavalier il est mal défendre mais
bon
et ça paraît assez dedans cette position
donc les les Blancs ont gagné un pion
mais c'est vraiment pas un beau pion
comme tu le disais puisqu'il est doublé
faible
et peut-être un jour on aurait non on
pourra pas le pousser dans ces 6 les
Noirs se développent avec tempo c'est
plutôt agréable qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
après qu'après Kamel c'est si c'est ce
qu'on le prend ce cavalier on donne la
paire de fou on recule Notre Dame
moi je bougeais madame parce que la part
de plus sacrée c'est sacré tu donnes pas
les coups comme ça
mais sur damakas j'ai peur de
la mettre en V2 cette dame peut-être
pour jouer à coup avec près
ben j'ai pas envie d'aller m'en fous
justement je serai faible aussi et si ce
genre de croire
et c'est pas trop je je suis pas fan de
laisser
4 qui a un petit centre allez chercher
peut-être cavalier
[Musique]
ils vont nous la prendre cette paire de
fou ils vont dans la récupérer j'ai
l'impression d'une autre
qui peuvent arriver
à 6 qui arrive c'est très embêtant
hyper embêtant qu'elle a des bouges
mais si je mets cavalier en D4 je peux
aussi perdre
ce truc là en plus chacun S4 qui arrive
encore une fois pas simple ouais non
d'ailleurs Giri qui est plongé dans une
réflexion assez profonde
elle est sûrement encore théorique
je pense pas qu'il soit surpris par la
poste qu'il a sur l'échiquier ça c'est
sûr qu'il risque je pense que guéri il
essaie de me rappeler un peu de sa
variante iris c'est un des joueurs quand
même aller mieux préparer peut-être même
le mieux préparé du monde
c'est peut-être le duel le duel entre
les deux joueurs les mieux préparés du
monde
c'est pas impossible c'est
pas possible
en tout cas les deux joueurs qui sont
très très bien préparés dans leur
ouverture et donc là bon petit débat
théorique je pense que tu vois la guéri
en plus tu n'as pas vu avant la caméra
mais il avait l'air ses lunettes c'est
frotter les yeux enfin tu vois comme si
il était en fait de se rappeler de de
ses ouvertures et de ses lignes
on avait dit que ça faisait nul dans
celle-là je crois qu'on a parié tous les
deux sur nul moi je change de pièce sur
kwana maintenant
ouais c'est pas très grave il y a rien
en jeu non non hésitez pas dans le chat
à lâcher vos pronostics aussi pour les
parties du jour
d'ailleurs j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
mots doux dans le chat éventuellement si
vous voulez un petit peu qui sont des
petits sondages voilà on a on a humé on
a pas tout
mais une pièce sur guérir mets ton petit
sondage en jeu après on verra
et mais moi j'ai parié nul et je vous
garantis que ça va faire nul ne croyez
pas Antoine qui est c'est de vous
influencer c'est pas bien ce que tu fais
ce qui paraîtront comme moi auront un
abonnement
un abonnement Premium
qui réfléchit beaucoup c'est Ariane tari
on a on a fait le tour là je crois de
tous les échiquiers et Ariane tarif ça
fait 20 minutes qu'on est parti sauf
qu'il est toujours au même endroit le la
mineur il y a encore une partie qu'on a
pas vu
c'est la partie de
c'est laquelle on l'a vu on a
pas vu ma mère et fille Rousseau en fait
je l'ai pas ouvert ici on a honnête on
est tout allait voir côté
là voilà
salut pour tout droit et bienvenue à toi
merci pour ton petit message mais Yuma
tu peux très bien créer
le sondage
mais si tu veux bien créer un petit truc
peut-être tu fais un sondage c'est pas
sur sur qui tu veux je te laisse une
partie un peu chaude une partie chaude
peut-être 45 peut-être fille ou c'est le
genre français
peut-être
tarif la grosse partie
un peu ce qu'on avait dit tu vois on
avait dit en début de partie que
cavalier 7 c'est le coup H3 petit rock
cavaler C3 d'aller soit en A4 pour les
capturer le foot à 5 soit en E2 G3
à 5 A4 ça c'était thématique
F6 voilà un plan normal
dame de tout Caval qui va venir en F8 ça
c'est entièrement normal parce qu'avec
il va venir généralement en E6 et voir
un peu ce qui se passe vous mettez pas
mal de points aussi sur le Dame des 7 ça
va être difficile de faire une rupture
avec les Blancs là du du F4 du D4 ça va
être compliqué non ben généralement on
joue pas trop des cartes
généralement c'est avec quelqu'un
je sais pas comment ça se passe est-ce
que la banque pour mettre la pression
sur la 5 je fais F4 derrière
pas trop comment ça se passe
généralement sur la rupture on va manger
en F4 avec les noirs
[Musique]
peut-être tu peux la faire maintenant
ouais peut-être oui
peut-être même des quatre échecs
[Musique]
il y a une position qui s'est un petit
peu ouvertes tu vois mais c'est vrai que
au final c'est quand même on rêve pour
les slots
[Musique]
qui a pas de problème
un jour aussi pour laisser passer la
tour
bon les blancs en plein de moyens de
pouvoir améliorer la position les blancs
aussi la Dame des deux tours c'est ça
c'est chaud le noir sont bien bah oui
c'est une position qui est assez connue
quand même donc c'est une position qui a
été étudiée depuis
là on a le 12 coups les noirs qui sont
en train de répéter le plan qui est
assez thématique et logique c'est alors
ces positions donc oui c'est il y a pas
eu de surprise pour l'instant ni avec
les blancs ni avec les Noirs
en termes de
de
[Musique]
théorie le joueur sont des productions
normales de cette ouverture il y a des
grosses réflexions un peu sur toutes les
tables n'a qu'à dont on parlait tout à
l'heure il est en train de réfléchir
depuis 12 minutes après le coup à 4 de
du jeune gouquettes
tari il est en train de réfléchir depuis
25 minutes maintenant
c'est quand même pas mal je vous
rappelle que c'est une partie en au cas
où donc au bout de deux heures dans deux
heures il y aura plus de temps plus du
tout
donc c'est des parties lentes mais
rapide ça peut ça peut finir en rapide
ouais je guéris il est depuis 9 minutes
au charbon là pour savoir où mettre sa
dame
et charia m'avait dit ça fait 11 minutes
après on pourrait peut-être retourner
voir un peu à l'IRESA
on n'a pas vu depuis un petit moment
aussi c'est vrai on va aller voir sa
partie alors donc cette position de
Paris on a déjà vu tout à l'heure on
fait un moment qu'on est bloqué ici
extrêmement compliqué on va aller voir
notre ami Ali resa c'était quitté sur
celle là avec après A6
et il y a eu donc feux de un
développement assez modeste mais ça
fd7 et food pourquoi pas le Caval BD7
vraie question je pense que tu as peur
de cavaler C6 exact et ça gagne en plus
pour les vents
tu peux te débarrasser du Fou sur échec
et de bouger la dame mais bon d'accord
que c'est pas forcément une bonne case
pour la dame j'ai juste vu la jauge
s'enflammait
ça pue ça pue un bref donc on met les
cavale F
et voilà et cette position je l'ai vu
c'est quoi la différence est-ce que si
elle Bloom je remonte le chat
16 5 au lieu de A6 dans la partie
actuelle c'était ma grosse ah d'accord
ok donc en fait
ici la place de A6 c'est ce qu'a joué
ici vente forest contre mcdoslo et c'est
marrant parce que tu vois
bon morceau de los c'est quand même un
genre iranien
[Musique]
quand même de base iranien
c'est possible de leur travail ensemble
je pense qu'ils sont pas de ces deux-là
même l'ouverture c'est encore autre
chose
et bon les deux Iraniens qui peuvent
tomber dans la même position ça c'est
marrant
et donc en tout cas c'est 5 c'était le
coup qui avait été joué par
par vent de Forest qui est toujours à
Serpentard donc c'est soit l'ouverture
et dans ces dans ces ouvertures il a
toujours des surprises à un concocté
très original et c'est ça que c'était
une position qui était un peu folle et
en fait les Blancs avaient complètement
rasé les Noirs il y avait une huile à la
fin et il y avait un bon raté mais
c'était super malin c'est super malin
c'est ça quand même parce que ça on peut
pas prendre parce que sinon
c'est la partie dans le
si je n'en opening je vais essayer non
il me dit que j'ai pas de partie mais
surprise en B5 s'il est blanc font
apprend B5 qui a pris ce D4 donc le
cavalier va être perdu
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ensuite là
non avec les Blancs
il faudrait rechercher là j'ai pas la
base de données ici là mais
il y avait eu un truc comme ça et je
sais plus comment ça s'est passé mais
c'était une partie complète moins folle
tu vas peut-être un truc comme ça
il avait donné la pièce
un truc du style là d'ailleurs
un truc comme ça je crois
waouh si j'ai retrouvé la partie sur un
génie mais je me dis quelque chose
maintenant que tout le monde et en fait
ok ok il y avait un truc comme ça alors
je sais plus les branchés je crois pas
de suite mais en fait tu avais regarde
tu as quatre pions pour les Noirs 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 pour les blancs tu as la paire
de fou beaucoup d'espace du mal à bouger
tes pièces je crois qu'il avait resté 6
à la place de français 4
un truc comme ça la partie je sais plus
c'était il y a une partie que il y a
quasiment 6 mois et que j'ai commandé
sur un petit peu
mesdames c'était trop beau regarde sur
d'apprendre des cartes comprendre des
cartes cette position c'est magnifique
et là on voit bien que les trois pions
valent valent bien une pièce elle va le
très très très bien une pièce tu te
croirais dans la variance hors de c'est
avec tous les petits pions qui avance et
non c'est quoi je m'arrête pour les pour
les noirs
donc bon je vais faire ça ça
doubler ce qu'on appelle
c'est une très très grosse domination en
tout cas c'était la partie un truc comme
ça la partie
de
de parram contre
Forest et là il a choisi l'approche
beaucoup plus prudente avec le coup à 6
ouais bon j'imagine que ça a été analysé
et que la variante de bonne soirée ce
n'est pas forcément la route et
[Musique]
donc là pour moi le coup assez évident
ça serait de prendre le cavalier en E5
pour ma main se débarrasser de la pièce
la mieux placée des blancs
mais oui
je sais pas si arrivé jusque là j'avais
la bonne ligne et bien sûr excuse-moi je
t'ai coupé non non pas de souci je me
disais que là le coup le plus évident
pour moi ça serait de prendre 5 pour
échanger la pièce la mieux placée des
blancs
et doubler des pions ouais après
tout de suite
mais en fait moi ce que j'ai peur pour
cette position c'est un jour 4
mais si tu regardes tu vas devoir le
faire maintenant
non c'est pas sûr encore le jour mais
de chance je pense à ça par exemple
ok ok mais bon
qui peut commencer à devenir dangereux
si on échange des dames maintenant
rock un jour
ça peut me permettre de nous c'est un
truc je sais pas si
c'est bon je supporte la dame Descartes
c'est pour ça pas mal de choses mais je
suis pas obligé de faire de faire F4
alors peut-être on fait ah oui on peut
pas commencer par la tour à 8 est
attaquée mais donc ça c'est pénible on
est obligé de faire C6 maintenant
on va changer d'âme jusqu'à mon plan là
et si un jour je regarderai 4 et mettre
mon rock ou quoi
ben écoute j'ai un gros centre et ta
majorité elle est ici ce côté là ça joue
alors il y a Yuma qui nous a envoyé la
partie je peux pas la copier parce que
là je suis pas dans l'analyse
malheureusement je suis dans dans
l'événement mais rapidement à l'aveugle
il y a eu quoi C5 des princesses 5
[Musique]
c'est à la place d'assis c'est 5 la
partie et il y a eu des Français 5 dames
après
[Musique]
on arrive à la même position
ouais je me souvenais à peu près des
thèmes et des idées pour début de la
vidéo et au final il a il a fini par
rendre un papa de ce pion là à la fin de
la circulaire
mais
et oui il a perdu la partie il a perdu
la partie avec les mains c'est vrai que
mais ok mais je crois qu'il avait mieux
à faire je crois que c'est si c'était
pas précis quoi d'abord il me semble
mais bon je sais plus c'était il y a
longtemps
une minute de réflexion moi il m'a fallu
que 30 secondes mais bon rien de tarif a
fini par trouver mon coup c'est à dire
D4
qui a joué ici des quatre ok
très bizarre
logique comme on avait dit on va
empêchait les cavaliers 5
on veut essayer de jouer au centre
d'ouvrir la colonne donc c'est assez
logique maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir essayer de faire avec les noms
alors
on avait l'idée de jouer éventuellement
sur un coup comme ça
ça et sur un truc comme ça j'avais
l'idée j'avais montré le Caval
Ier
est-ce que dans cette ligne après des
quatre j'ai pas E5
et sur dessin cavalier des 4 même idée
intéressant
tactiquement ça la jaune semble nous
dire que ça marche pas mais F3 revient
et
et ça m'a pas apparemment
le truc avec tour G5 marche pas
parce que maintenant il y a aussi le fou
qui peut prendre en G5 qui avait pas ça
tout à l'heure
ok bon
toi tu cherches les thèmes tout de suite
pour aller mater les rois alors on a vu
l'idée donc pourquoi pas la reproduire
en fait dans celle-là et merci beaucoup
tous mes chougats pour le pour le prime
merci à toi
merci pour ton soutien
donc voilà des quatre cinq en tout cas
c'est le coup que j'en garderai c'est le
tu vois c'est un coup qui a l'air
assez
bon quoi mais ça accélère l'ouverture du
centre est-ce que les noirs peuvent
souhaiter accélérer l'ouverture du
centre dans ce dans ce dans cette
position
elle est blanc là le ferme mais ils
peuvent aussi l'ouvrir ah oui mais je
veux venir quand même à la base je
comptais par cavale 5 je pense donc et
merci beaucoup ma liquide pour le pour
le prime merci à vous les gars c'est le
moment si vous voulez lancer de prime
c'est maintenant ne laissez pas traîner
que la chaîne allez-y lancer un train de
live ça fait très plaisir ouais merci
merci à vous en tout cas les gars pour
votre soutien et et pour pour être là et
pour et pour au petit Seb ça fait très
plaisir
grave donc avec ici l'idée c'est de
faire Cavalo 5
voilà
donc l'idée de faire cavale 5 maintenant
il l'a battu enfin il l'a complètement
annulé ouais mais avec ça ça si tu
prends ben j'arrive
ouais tu arrives quand même en fait tu
arrives à tes fins voilà donc la
position elle est ouverte mais bon j'ai
l'attaque quand même donc il faut voir
que
le roi il est ouvert tout ça c'est bien
pour les blancs mais d'un autre côté bah
écoute je sais pas
je vais ouvrir mais je suis pas
totalement prêt non plus pour ouvrir ni
pour me défendre et comme des pièces
sur attaque quoi tu vois ok
noir avec les Blancs tu ferais descendre
un peu mou non je voudrais des cinq mais
là maintenant voir est-ce qu'on fait
parce que je peux aussi faire ça ça et
puis
F4 là pour défendre la case la case 2
on va même pouvoir défendre latéralement
avec la avec la dame éventuellement sur
la troisième
découverte un peu pénible aussi mais bon
je syncoo que j'aime pas vous êtes mais
dans l'idée tu mets ton fous pour
défendre ben écoute
c'est intéressant comme position on voit
que les on voit que positionnellement
c'est ça peut être que beaucoup mieux
pour les blancs mais les Noirs ont une
attaque quoi en fait concrètement les
noirs ont des choses mais si jamais
blanc dans une position beaucoup plus
solide ouais donc ça c'est clair
après le 5 c'est pas forcément le goût
moi j'ai vu l'idée avec dommage 4
proactive je voulais
on aurait des petits confessions
confessionaux qui traînent j'en ai un
qui était petit si vous voulez j'ai eu
quoi attends
ça peut être sympa ça
j'ouvre tout vous allez voir la caméra
qui est saute et merde dans le coin
c'est pas du tout
55 ans de fin des votes dans 7 minutes
entre Paris et d'où cette Europe vous
avez mis 50 50 c'est complètement dingue
ok alors j'ai eu quoi là en fait j'en ai
j'en ai un milliard on est 1 2 3 à 4 5 6
on va peut-être pas regarder les 6 on va
faire une petite sélection peut-être
j'ai
toutes les pré-game en fait j'ai pris
game ouais c'est pas
sympa il a perdu
sinon j'ai un amour après game j'ai Fabi
pregame Paris ma média Rohff Wesley ce
qui m'intéresse c'est Magnus
vu qu'il a perdu hier peut-être voir un
petit peu ce qui va nous dire ça vous
dit je te regarde en anglais et je vous
traduis après il faut que je le je le
télécharge
pour quelques secondes et puis je vais
vous le hop
je vais vous le mettre de suite
allez on va se voir ça ça fait ça fait
une petite pause pour nous en fait
environ de une minute
il y a un point d'interrogation pour
Abdou il n'arrive pas à tout je pense
qu'on va lui on va lui donner des cours
alors
[Musique]
c'était court mais surtout c'était en
norvégien surtout
[Rires]
désolé
j'entends pas on m'a rien dit on peut
traduire sur langage corporel il était
boudeur clairement il voulait pas
répondre aux questions il est passé un
peu un peu rapidement il a esquivé la
deuxième ça paraît de Wesley Sow il a
tracé et le journaliste a dit lequel
voilà
bon sens
voilà voilà
mais c'était marrant on a appris un peu
norvégien et ça serait bien alors hier
il y a que Nakamura je crois que
qu'un prix le parti de faire un
confessionnal pendant la ronde
mais faut dire aussi que c'était le seul
qui avait une partie assez calme quand
même globalement oui oui
il a besoin d'aller parler pendant sa
partie c'est un vrai communiqué ouais
c'est vrai mais là par exemple faire
venir un petit Paris c'est très cool
quoi
c'est quoi l'idée de Damas 5 à mon avis
c'est de la ramener en H5 déjà là il y a
une petite menace Kratos
c'est cavaler prend des cartes
sera plus détendu donc ça va être
difficile bon le problème c'est que même
si on voit pas la menace même si on
regarde les points parce que j'ai quand
même plein de coups qui parlent à menace
et qui sont des coups de développement
assez logique cavale C3 pareil père
logique foudé deux pareil hyper logique
avec tempo mais clairement cette dame
elle est pas venue en A5 pour y rester
je pense que va revenir sur le roi bien
sûr elle est arrivée il vient ici et
puis il va t'inquiète pas donc une fois
que c'est dommage simple tu auras les
idées de cavaliers prend des cartes
encore une fois dévier escalier et
maintenant
un peu la musique que j'avais avec
dommage 4 tu vois
tout à fait est-ce que elle serait pas
une idée alors je sais pas si on a le
temps tout de suite justement parce que
là il y a la menace cavale D4 mais à
moyen terme une idée de faire G3
fougères pour se défendre avec les
blancs ou est-ce que le plan H5 H4 est
trop dangereux je j'aime pas ouais ouais
en fait il met du temps à venir chercher
mon roi il mène du temps à venir
attaquer vraiment à mon roi et j'ai
trois je lui donne une rupture en H4
et en plus un coup je perds deux temps
pour me pseudo défendre alors qu'il va
réussir à avoir une rupture tu vois j'ai
l'impression
que j'ai deux plutôt comme ça mon
impression je me trompe peut-être donc
là une suite possible ça peut être les
blancs se développent par cavalier C3
dash 5 menace cavalier prend des 4
et
3 est-il un coup il faut pour ça faut F4
contre c'est mieux mais après je pensais
aussi à X4 direct
[Musique]
quand même qui va aller en dessin
qui va pouvoir éventuellement passer par
E2 et G3 si il faut revenir en défense
très rapidement
salut patoche salut patoche
non c'est clair
non
ça couperait en plus la route de la dame
vers le vers les lois ouais
pas forcément la menace alors peut-être
qu'on fait un petit coup de fou des deux
avant
et donc cette fois F4 pour venir
défendre le pion h25
tout simplement et là la jauge qui a
l'air de prendre beaucoup de plaisir à
côté blanc bah ouais en fait tu as pas
de attaque mais tu as enfin je défends
quoi tu vois
une menace
j'ai beaucoup de mal à croire à la
pollution des Noirs en plus extrêmement
difficile tout est ouvert et j'ai
l'impression que les tactiques des
blancs vont
un peu regarde pour bien comprendre
damla c'est une tactique ça va marcher
il y a plein de choses qui peuvent
traîner et ça m'a l'air hyper dur et
pour les blancs ça s'est passé une fois
que tu arrives
enfin si jamais tu arrives à mettre ton
fou en défense bien
c'est un peu bizarre et finalement tes
pièces pour attaquer sont pas si
développer que ça
le foot casse voir on sait pas ce qu'il
fait et on sait pas comment et de quelle
manière il pourra rejoindre l'attaque un
jour
cavalier bah il peut plus passer par 5
alors il peut passer par D4 mais on a vu
qu'il y a pas mal de moyens de
l'empêcher
le foot casse blanche bon bah il peut
pas sacrifier sur H3 il y a plus de H3
compliqué de continuer l'attaque là pour
les noirs et ça se passe plutôt très
bien pour les blancs qui pourraient se
continuer par se développer
tranquillement
en tout cas je je j'aime pas du tout ce
que nous fait ce que nous fait ici
qui est un peu emprunté là qui joue des
plans je pense qu'il avait ce plan cette
grande idée et qu'en fait il
concrètement là après des quatre c'est
pas une très bonne
un très bon plan de le jouer ici dans
cette position mais en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il a voulu surprendre
Paris ouais
et c'est lui qui se retrouve surpris
donc
c'est un peu des fois le contrecoup de
jouer une ouverture un peu bizarre après
encore une fois c'est ça reste à voir
est-ce qu'on se fait encore un petit
tour
par exemple
numéro 3 ici
on s'est arrêté à 4 de la part des
blancs ouais d'accord bien réfléchi et
il a choisi effectivement de faire B4
comme on envisageait
les cavale E4 donc il a il est pas allé
pour ton plan de cavale B1 Caval D2 et 4
il a choisi d'échanger Naka a choisi
d'échanger en 4 et la dernière pièce
mineure blanche est venue se développer
en E3
et Naka qui accepte les échanges là il
met son cavalier au bord en position
cavalier mvl je pense qu'il serait assez
content d'échanger sous de case blanche
ouais échanger puis mettre le installer
une pièce au centre alors
éventuellement peut-être un B8 pour
venir défendre ce fou ici
qu'est-ce qu'on peut vivre du cavalier
ce qui va revenir en arrière ou est-ce
qu'il veut essayer de s'installer un
jour sur une case en B3
j'ai plus de sortie j'ai l'impression
tu vois quand tu rentres on va faire
attention que tu puisses bien ressortir
c'est un peu comme tu es comme quand tu
sors de chez toi
[Musique]
mon Cavalaire en B3 tu auras toujours la
Casa 5 d'où tu es venu mais bon oui
c'est vrai ce serait bien triste de
devoir y retourner
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut peut-être
Dame des trois ou deux mais ok bon on a
qu'à qui et qui voudrait solide on a
encore ce pion en DK qui est isolé tout
à l'heure on en parlait on en parle
aussi hier du pion des quatre que les
noirs doivent essayer d'échanger les
pièces et de bloquer le pion isolé
pièces en D5 tandis que les blancs
doivent avoir un jeu assez dynamique et
essayer de faire valoir un peu ce lapaq
grâce à des cases qu'on pourrait
utiliser pendant cavaliers
éventuellement et ramener les pièces
aussi à attaque donc là ça paraît très
logique un coup que tu as proposé un
pour
ça a été joué bah voilà
mais avant de la mettre en H5 j'aimerais
bien faire un plan avec H4 H4 H5
peut-être tu vois et après
une fois que tu as mis le four bien
tu aimes bien
je veux faire ça et je veux te forcer je
veux t'empêcher de faire j'ai 6 et je
veux te sacrifier dans la tronche et
mater ouais bah oui c'est possible après
même H4 pour faire intéressant à avoir
ce cavalier
solide en G5 là et chaque toujours fort
c'est toujours fort H4
intéressant moi je vois dans mes minutes
a été joué il a joué un petit fou bien
une petite pièce sur sur combien ah bah
je pense que c'est le meilleur couche
totalement d'accord avec toi et si Caval
vient en B3 où est-ce qu'on met notre
tour c'est quand même ben c'est deux
pour commencer à ça
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu le voir
nous-même sur la jauge
donc ok bon une partie une partie chaude
il y a plein de choses à dire
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des questions
à nous poser ou quoi que ce soit ou des
choses en tête en tout cas n'hésitez pas
à me faire part à nous poser des
questions à nous parler on essaiera de
vous répondre bah il y a pas de toche
justement qui ne parlait du pion h bah
tu vois patoche l'écran essence se
rencontrent
2 en cette partie là elle purement et
puis sortir le flou oui H5 fois 6
clairement être une idée ici
mais bon pour l'instant j'ai pas mangé
là non un peu long j'imagine mais
oui ça peut être
ça peut être pas mal quelqu'un a une
carte genre comme la plus map qui
recense les échiquier en extérieur par
hasard cherche tout à l'heure j'ai
seulement trouvé un article
[Musique]
je ne peux pas t'aider je suis désolé
tu passes par non
mon cher Billy n'hésite pas à passer au
Jardin des Plantes où il y a toujours
des joueurs toute l'année
surtout quand il fait beau à Paris tu as
le fameux Jardin de Luxembourg bien sûr
si à Cannes sur la Croisette
quasiment tout le temps
et
après
je sais qu'à Nice sur la coulé vert
qu'on a aussi des chéquiers mais par
contre je vois beaucoup moins de joueurs
ah ouais c'est très récent alors parce
que quand j'habitais à Nice il y avait
pas ça
quand même quelques années quand même
ouais ouais d'accord
[Musique]
j'ai vécu à Nice mais c'était assez il y
a 10 ans quand même
ok ça marche moi aussi
on a dû se croiser
jusqu'à
2000 2015 2016
moi jusqu'à 2013
et après en 2016 je suis parti à Cannes
pareil très loin ah ouais gros gros
explorateurs
assez bizarre je crois qu'il y a un
utilisateur qui s'appelle robinside mais
je vois pas ses messages dans le chat
tu pourras le traduire
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
rien de spécial journée n'est pas là
pour parler de ma piètre carrière de
joueurs d'échec amateur mais plutôt pour
parler des champions dont Ariane tari
qui vient de jouer avec
quand tu parles de champion on peut
aussi parler de championne peut-être il
m'a confessé hier que tu avais joué
contre Fatou en interclub
c'est pour toi
j'ai une excuse on a fêté un peu trop la
victoire la veille d'accord ok mais elle
a très bien joué aussi ce qui n'a pas
arrangé mes affaires
ok alors
c'est quand ta prochaine vidéo ouverte
c'est quoi une vidéo ouverte
YouTube
[Musique]
j'ai pas encore
prévu de faire tout ça mais mais je vous
dirai pour l'instant mais très bientôt
il va y avoir des des grosses nouveautés
chez stouf je suis pas d'ici à peu près
un mois une chose qui vont sortir mais
pour l'instant je vous dirai rien je
vous laisserai découvrir en temps voulu
B7 non B7 c'est pas trop en prise parce
que la dame elle est enfermée je crois
après après tour bélite malheureusement
quand tu mets une dame là-haut il faut
toujours que tu fasses attention si elle
peut rentrer à la maison quand même
parce que sinon elle est perdue
OK
[Musique]
cette fois hein en tout cas je sais pas
vous mais moi j'aime bien la position
est blanc moi j'aime beaucoup les blancs
aussi dans cette position on l'adore
cette position et là pour suivre pour
suivre la logique il faudrait qu'il
fasse tout de suite j'imagine damage 5
en fait mais nous on a déjà vu que foue
F4 et fou G3 c'était ultra solide comme
défense et lui il l'a vu aussi donc là
de dire Beck il est en train de se dire
oh là mon plan c'est c'est pas terrible
en fait
mais il faut bien il faut bien
maintenant qu'il a commencé il faut bien
continuer quoi ok
c'est une bonne question ici
[Musique]
robinside et je l'ai pas vu cette
position c'est marrant qui est des
quatre on en a parlé on a dit que cavale
C3 ça a évité qu'elle va le prendre des
4 justement tout à l'heure quand on
analysé
en fait dans cette partie dans cette
position on a moi j'ai pensé à ça et sur
un comme E6 on joue un coup comme ça il
y a cavaler des quatre qui est possible
à cause de cavaler prend des quatre et
d'un HK F2 et HK ça c'est un truc qu'on
a énoncé à après on a regardé cavaliers
F3 d'un point H2 et même penser à
tourger 5 qui me lasse mat et sur
Cavalera puis on prend on avait dit que
c'était quasiment maths imparable et que
le noir était gagnant ça on en a parlé
ensuite on a parlé de il y a eu des
quatre là et on a parlé de E5
suivi de D5 cavaliers des 4 sur
cavaliers prend on a pensé à pion
prendre à 4 on a aussi pensé à H4 avec
la même idée
par exemple si je reviens là ben là tu
as du mal à ramener la tour parce que je
comprends par exemple voilà tu as pas
trop trop de de suite donc on a pensé à
tout ça et après son Damas 5 on a dit
que waouh ça menace cave à les prendre
des cartes parce que tu aurais dame
prend un mais on avait dit que le
meilleur moyen de défendre de se
défendre contre quelqu'un
mais maintenant il y a une autre
tactique que Samy souligne encore une
fois c'est qu'elle va les prendre des
quatre et en fait c'est la même idée
sauf que le problème c'est qu'après
dommage 5 ici et ben j'ai plus d'un
problème de
ça c'est le le gros souci et après
cavalier F3 je crois qu'il y a plus
grand chose pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'a
donné cette pièce Sami est-ce que
c'était ça ton objectif c'était
ce que
j'ai 7 ouais mais bon j'ai quand même
beaucoup de pièces je doute que ça
marche sur d'autres choses je vais
réussir à même d'un premier cette maison
aussi être un coup non là je je suis
d'accord mais également H4 c'était
clairement une idée qu'on a dénoncé
plusieurs fois dans plusieurs par an
depuis tout à l'heure
mais alors là
je vais refaire quand même mettre le
four en G3 et ça va être une solide
quand même
revient en F3 en fait juste non mais ok
ok
[Musique]
ça a mis c'est un peu un hacker il
cherche à créer le danger un peu partout
ouais juste
sur fouet 3 tu vas faire tout prendre
des cartes celui de dommage simple
et partir
ça commence à faire peur cette position
éventuellement
peut-être que c'est possible qu'elle
prend des 4 ans
je vais lancer l'ordi moi pour voir
enfin j'ai juste regardé sur l'ordi
effectivement on sait ça comme meilleur
coup mais il dit plus un pour les blancs
quand même donc je regarde pas la ligne
bizarre mais mais en pratique c'était
vrai que c'est sympa ça pour répondre à
la question de ryanou il me demande
combien j'ai de l'eau je suis
18-40 à peu près
un peu moins même
en mvl il a joué le
Francesco
c'était je crois en Roumanie il y a
quelques quelques jours
la prochaine étape de
ton programme je ne le connais pas là et
après tout Top 16 donc je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont mais hésitez pas à aller sur
son site mvl mvl chess il est génial il
fait des blogs où il raconte un peu
chacun de ces tournois avec il met des
petites musiques qui l'ont inspiré à ces
moments là enfin c'est vraiment très
agréable à lire allez sur le site mvl
chess pour suivre sa carrière
si hier vous parlez d'un petit jeune en
quelques années oui en bas pas sûr on
parlait de on parlait d'un pot d'horreur
on parlait aussi de bookes
[Musique]
me paraît vraiment me paraissait
vraiment bizarre parce qu'après dommage
5 je voyais vraiment pas la suite ouais
c'est une ligne intéressante là tu étais
pas assez sur ouais non pour rester sur
la naudir bec là on sera Ariane la ligne
de Samy est vraiment très intéressante
parce qu'après Caval prend des quatre
Caval prend des 4 fugé 7 qui était le
coût proposé par Sami l'ordinateur ne
donne plus qu'un seul coup qui laisse
avantage blanc c'est E5
ah oui et ça c'est Dingo quand même
ça veut dire qu'on a rien compris à la
position quoi
les problèmes en fait là je me lance
5 il faut donner la cale ok ok
et ben
ça prévoit un peu d'artifice dans les
cookies viennent en fait parce que on a
rien compris à la pause et même avec
l'ordi c'est compliqué c'est ouf et
pourquoi on sacrifie alors bon j'imagine
qu'il y a trop de jeux et qu'on a envie
de remettre le cavalier là et de
mais ça a l'air hyper compliqué quoi
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que moi je
voyais pas d'où faire ça
et ça et après il y a avoir rien et
juste le faire ouvrir quoi en fait
cavale prend des quatre il va sans doute
le trouver Abdou par par élimination
quoi mais est-ce qu'il aurait pas besoin
de penser
parce que est-ce que tu penses
qu'il va
gentillement un jeu de terme je vais
dévisse donc pas de respect du tout à ce
que a fait Abdou mais en fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est que je veux pas
qu'elle va les prendre des quatre les
balles à bosemont c'est complètement
écrasante en fait oui c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il va le trouver par
élimination non mais en fait que je
pense qu'il va le jouer en fait je pense
que dans ma 5 il avait déjà calculé
qu'avec mon écran
pourquoi ça fait 10 minutes qu'il
réfléchit alors
en fait pour moi tu joues pas un coup si
concret si t'as pas la suite parce que
en fait Damas 5 c'est toujours pas
qu'elle va les prendre des quatre enfin
parce que je joue dans H5 bah j'ai
l'impression quand même que ça se passe
pas bien quand même un coup comme ça
on a vu que ça marchait pas du tout donc
bon c'est pour ça que peut-être que je
me dis qu'il en tout cas il a déjà pensé
à le faire maintenant il va peut-être
vérifier tout ça et voilà quoi mais
effectivement il peut faire aussi juste
du Fou G7
[Musique]
encore une fois
sans ordi
[Musique]
de faire des 5 c'est vrai que ça coupe
un peu la dame mais d'un autre côté j'ai
peur de me faire empiler la tour là
c'est peut-être pas forcément
super ce que je viens de faire ouais
peut-être développer un petit coup de
fou de case noire avant
soit FF4 ça paraît le à être un très
grand coup là on peut pas le faire là on
peut pas donner des cas tout de suite
peut-être juste des cinq
et sur
ça
il va sans doute jouer sept ou qu'elle
va le prendre à quatre en fait
il va voir que c'est les deux seules
options à mon avis active à sa
disposition et que damage 5 évidemment
c'est une fausse bonne idée
ça ouvre la diagonale
noire et ça sent que c'est pas bon par
contre E5 qui est des 5 c'est les coûts
qui visuellement c'est un peu des
réflexes
là et empêcher un peu la dame de venir
en se faire H5 est-ce que ça te dirait
de voir de quoi accoucher à niche guéri
après 20 minutes de réflexion allez on
était rendu au 14e coups Fabienne
ocarwin va être développé son deuxième
cavalier en C6 et on avait parlé de la
case B2 on avait dit que surtout fallait
pas prendre ce cavalier fallait le
garder la paire de fou et la jouer de
dames A4 vous avez dit que j'aimais pas
à cause de A6 8 ou DSL gagner du temps
sur la dame mais après les deux ça me
posait des problèmes avec un vase
qu'elle va le 5 a vite été joué et il a
encore réfléchi il a réfléchi 26 minutes
encore à niche avant de jouer fou des
quatre ok ben là c'est con là
il est perdu en plus j'ai du cavalier 3
donc il faut faire un truc donc
assis on va prendre 5 en fait on n'a pas
le choix
donc foulard à 6
[Musique]
prise
à 4
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on a là
5 prises à 5
vous décides
est-ce que tu vas réussir à
à mettre mon foot en case blanc
ça se peut que ce soit dur à passer la
casse B3 peut être sympa pour le
cavalier noir mais après des blancs
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on peut pas
échanger les dames si on fait après 5
dames après assis ça toujours après à 6
,5
mais bon c'était cloué mais bon
je pense que ça va je reste un sur que
j'avais annoncé depuis le début
mais pourquoi pas après il a bougé son
cavalier il est pas rentré avec A6 la
vente la plus tendue il y avait autre
chose qui me qui me qui me turlupiner
c'était que qu'est-ce qui se passait
après
cinq dames 5
qui restent en prix
donc je pense tu as besoin de garder ce
case noire quand même
[Musique]
c'est un peu moqué de ce coup là mais
est-ce que c'est oui oui c'est débile je
joue
qui est pas mal
ouais bah si obligé de manger 5 par
contre en tout cas toutes ces
complications fantasmagoriques qu'elles
ont été évitées par Fabienne o'carwanak
a simplement reculer son son Caval en G6
et qui menace plus vraiment
à 6
si elle veut qui retire sa progression
de président après coup et 8 mais en
fait je cherche des possibilités à
chaque fois je vais être sûr que les
coups soient forcés en fait il faut 8
ben en fait juste
je menace quand même des doubles menaces
tu vois ça pour ça que je regarde un peu
ce genre de coup mais c'est vrai que je
suis pas fan c'est un peu bizarre
le fou il est pas trop attaché hein
mais bon oui c'est un coup
[Musique]
je pense 30 secondes et après tu passes
à autre chose
un bon coup
et là maintenant que
sa pièce en
comment on continue avec les Blancs
est-ce qu'on Roque tout simplement
est-ce qu'on oui on a le temps de roquet
tranquillement là
on a rien en prise
je pense qu'on va tout simplement ok
qu'est-ce qu'on pense aussi
je veux
en profiter et c'est l'ouvrir les
cadenas c'est quoi
opposée ici j'aimerais bien
et maintenant on va se développer avec
vous aussi et sur H5 on va simplement
faire Caval le 7 par exemple ah non ça
serait mieux de faire Caval le 7 d'abord
pour pouvoir faire hacher sur H5
c'est parce que tu en penses mais
[Musique]
mais bon je pense que c'est pas un coup
après Aniche là il vient de passer
beaucoup de temps
dans l'ouverture enfin là dans le
dernier coup à réfléchir et ouais
peut-être qu'il veut juste une position
tranquille mais il peut pas se permettre
il peut pas se permettre de jouer une
pose trop complexe et lui reste moins
d'une heure c'est-à-dire moins de la
moitié du temps pour jouer 23 coups il y
aura pas d'incrément
qui peut pas se permettre de rentrer
dans les applications trop puissantes
oui et puis en plus il sent que hyper un
peu les pédales dans la partie et ben
c'est bien des fois de d'avoir un peu le
contrôle et que du coup comme petit rock
pour pas trop partir en cacahuète
tout à fait donc ok bah écoute position
qui est toujours à peu près
normal c'est assez intéressant ce qui
s'est passé chez Ali resa et charme
média Rohff ouais
je pense qu'on peut aller voir
après le coup cavale F7 Caval D7 cavalf
17 de mai et fouet 300 l'avait vu et
ensuite il a joué C6
le joueur azéri
il a envoyé à 6 qui a eu cavale prend
des 7 cavale prend des 7 il y a Eurock
il y a eu le fou en B7
et là dame 1 F5 ah c'est assez critique
je veux bien que tu m'éclaires un peu
sur ce carbone se passer c'est tout
sur la loi ramenez la dame par là pour
attaquer hein
et dès que les Noirs réagissent par ces
cinq a priori on va jouer on va jouer
des cinq je pense pour tuer le coup et
avoir un peu passé protégé et pourquoi
ils ont fait ces six les Noirs avant bah
pour détendre le plus long B5 j'imagine
que le pion pouvait être en prise un
jour
je sais pas
effectivement c'est 5 ça va être la
rupture ça va être la deuxième rupture
des Noirs cette position
dès que tu le fais je fais des non ça ça
fait passer protégé par le pion 4 et ton
fruit devient mauvais j'ai des cases
aussi en C6 les plus on en sont faibles
et donc ça s'est pas mal pour les blancs
et du coup il y a 5 c'est l'autre
il y a eu F5
mais avec qui il veut tout de suite
s'attaquer au beau centre blanc qui veut
pas laisser
aller réserves
qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on pousse
5 pour avoir un pion passé central on va
se prendre F4 dans ce cas là j'imagine
[Musique]
on a perdu tout ok je me disais bien
je passais des choses bizarres sur ce
film
est-ce que vous m'entendez encore
et salut Joseph bienvenue Joseph
ok on va retrouver ce qu'apparemment est
passé sous le bureau là il est en plein
Pitt stop
il est en plein stop bon bah je
t'inquiète Stéphane
donc on est sur le F5 le F5 de charia
mammédia Rohff et ça a été pris par Ali
resa ça a été pris c'est un choix un
choix responsable dans cette position là
qu'on voit actuellement il aurait pu
maintenir son centre en gardant un pion
4 ah souffre
ouais c'est bon
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai ma et mon
micro qui sont débranchés tout seul pas
débrancher mais c'était branché ma
souris marchait plus et mon micro là
donc j'avais fait que c'est quand même
bien le micro le bon micro parce que vu
que je l'ai débranché rebranché il se
peut que ça pas le bon micro
ah c'était bizarre je comprenais pas ce
qui se passait je croyais que j'étais
déconnecté mais c'était toi j'ai perdu
et pendant que tu étais sous le bureau
mon gerstouf elle est résa a pris une
décision radicale il s'est emparée du
pion F5
ouais alors ça c'est c'est un drôle de
choix quand même ouais c'est bizarre
parce que voilà l'idée que j'allais
expliquer c'est que sur un coup comme le
5 et ben ce que veut parce que vous
voulez avoir le contrôle de la case D5
vous pouvez imaginer un coup comme par
exemple vous prend cette prend pour
éliminer le défenseur principal de la
case des 5 d'accord et après
maintenant j'ai un super cavalier est à
la paire de fou mais la pression est
fermée et les Français dans la position
ouverte donc c'est complètement
jouable et intéressant pourtant c'est le
fameux cavalier Blokker cher à ninjovic
c'est ça c'est ça et donc là
on peut peut-être aussi penser à du F4
qui pour arriver et ça qui est 4 ça
empêche pas évidemment j'ai trois
dommage 4 et ça fait moins un peu la
position on aurait du mal à avoir des
ruptures avec les lents et il a pris il
a pris F5
j'imagine qu'il a un weekend nouvelle
mais je pensais aussi à un genre comme
F4
blanche mais bon je sais pas attends
ferme ton food case noire et devient et
devient horrible ouais mais si jamais F4
ou G4 F5 essayer de je sais pas mais
c'est vrai que c'est un coup assez
bizarre quand même 5
et voir un petit et maintenant la
rupture C5 elle va beaucoup mieux
marcher pour les Noirs en plus parce que
le dessin que ça sera nul c'est plus dur
c'est plus dur à faire
donc ok c'est un choix vraiment qui va
changer toute la dynamique de la
politique on va aller voir ça après et
après
ce qui a une tactique
peut-être juste que j'ai foutu cette
truc que j'ai essayé de faire
24 maintenant pas terrible c'est pas
trop ce qu'on voulait
sur F4 je pense
un peu à prendre une décision et moi je
vais venir sur sa case là que
je voulais pas me bloquer je sais pas
intéressant je pense que
je pense que il avait juste peur de
F4 notre ami raisin
pour ça qu'il a mangé maintenant
on va un petit peu
où j'ai 5
je crois pas trop
[Musique]
au pire des cas je prends la il prend la
et je prends un H2 sur échec au pire des
cas je suis là
pire pire pire pire des gaz mais
peut-être que j'ai encore mieux que ça
hein
[Musique]
la question c'est comment est-ce que je
continue
le coup préféré de la jauge c'était
c'était pas forcément de prise c'était
il aimait bien aussi conserver la
tension avec damser mais après avoir
joué dame 1 ça paraît évidemment très
bizarre de remettre la dame en serre
c'est pas un coup très humain quoi et ma
mec qui a décidé de reprendre
tranquillement le pion de toute façon il
a pas vraiment le choix
qu'est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
peut-être dame ou pas est-ce que c'est
un trou d'un beurre idée d'attaquer la
tour me découler et les faire qu'un Mali
c'est pas mal ouais
le tour va simplement revenir peut-être
en F7
car elle est là
ok
là attention
ouh là là tu veux me faire des misères
j'ai failli oublier le petit coup en E3
peut-être fou là
ok ça j'avais pas vu Caval F6 quand même
[Musique]
moi j'ai la colonne g j'ai
7 et je me lasse tout reprocher 3 déjà
alors je peux pas faire la fourchette je
crois à cause de ça
et je perds trop de pièces il me semble
va manger quand même deux pièces pour la
dame pour la pour la tour mais je vais
essayer de bouger mon oups vous voulez
faire coudre
c'est clairement une idée aussi mais par
contre quand même B3 enfin j'aime bien
commencer ça gagne un tempo
bah ouais franchement le truc c'est que
ça a pas trop bougé chez Abdou il a joué
il a mis 22 minutes il a choisi
finalement fougée 7 après avoir sans
doute beaucoup considéré qu'elle va les
prendre des quatre
ici que fougères sans doute était plus
prudent il peut pas aller allé tout de
suite même si on avait vu qu'il y a
récupéré la pièce dans pas mal de
variantes
et là le meilleur coup c'est quand même
5 selon la turbine donc
c'est très compliqué là donc tourner par
exemple on aura peut-être du 5
parce que je mange quand même là
parce que si je prends la
et que je fais ça
par contre
donc ça paraît très difficile de ça
non mais sans doute que il va trouver
aussi encore une fois par
élimination
une fois qu'il aura fait le tour des
menaces noires
cavale dessin que ce serait pas des
coups ça
donc
F3 échec
alors pourquoi la photo pour jouer un
coup bah écoute c'est la meilleure joue
du monde et
dans la position il calcule
parce que c'est pas du tout con parce
qu'ils ont vu ce qu'on voit ils l'ont vu
ça fait 20 minutes
donc il vérifie des varans très très
profondes on peut pas on peut pas savoir
exactement lesquels tout le temps parce
que ça va ça va se ré ça va très loin
c'est la Grand Maître de ce niveau là
les meilleurs grands maîtres ça calcule
ça peut calculer jusqu'à 15 coups plus
loin
ouais mais c'est les joueurs qui
ont des puissances de calcul avant c'est
monstrueuse donc tout ce que nous on
voit à l'oeil nu dites vous bien que eux
ils le voient pareil en mieux et
beaucoup plus vite que nous
instantanément il le voit instantanément
et ensuite ici il pousse toujours plus
loin toujours plus loin E5 a été joué
par Ariane tarif quoi apparemment
c'est pas
si on prend je ferai bien
j'en prends ou qu'elle va le prendre les
deux ont l'air OK
c'était non c'était sur la Ligue qui va
le prendre des quatre d'abord avant faut
que j'achète
et là le meilleur coup c'était E5 il
fallait donner la cale sur sur
[Musique]
le matériel parce que les noirs sont
quatre fois dessus et nous on écoute
trois fois dessus
pas les 15 coups de suite c'est de
calculer 15 coups c'est parce qu'ils ont
calculé très longtemps en profondeur
mais avec plein de variations donc leur
adversaire ne joue pas forcément
exactement le coup auquel il s'attendait
et puis vérifie tout à chaque fois en
fait
ils peuvent avoir vu qu'un spoil avance
à chaque coup tu revérifier
tu peux voir déjà tu peux voir un coup
plus loin à chaque fois donc faut tout
remettre et puis quand tu as la position
comme sur les chéquier tu vois mieux
quand tu avances dans les couilles donc
c'est normal de revérifier tu peux avoir
raté quelque chose dans tes variante et
te rendre compte au bout de quelques
coups et du coup tu peux essayer de
rebondir sur un coup quand c'est des
gens encore
égale dans une Espagnole face à Wesley
souk et très solide là la position la
plus intéressante je pense qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment cette
sicilienne tendue entre le jeune Ariane
Paris et Abdou sa torov là pour toi il
faudra absolument prendre le 5
terrible en fait de si les blancs
prennent en D6 c'est juste catastrophe
à moins qu'il y ait une tactique directe
avec
[Musique]
j'ai 4
jours
puis on prend
et là on peut imaginer
en fait 4 et on va perdre une pièce
[Musique]
je pense que
ah non j'avais mis nul
moi je change pas d'avis
en vrai non mais on a un peu manqué de
respect Ariane tari déjà hier on le
voyait on le voyait se faire cabosser
par mamedia Rohff il a il a fait mieux
que te tenir
il l'a mis en difficulté là aujourd'hui
qu'on sera Abdou bah il est quand même
considérablement mieux
donc je pense que
[Musique]
alors
je posais je suis assez content il est
toute ma ligne hors connexion cannoise
connexion cannoise
et centraliser un peu les pièces bloquer
isolé maintenant je me regarde un coup
comme cavalier des deux
et commencer à ramener un peu la dame
empêcher cavalier B3 et aussi fou C4
éventuellement
pour l'instant bon il peut mater mais en
cas où il paraît mettre le rang à l'abri
et les idées avec H4 dont on parlait
tout à l'heure ouais
tu as bien aimé cette partie c'est la
partie de Magnus où il a fait G4 H4
et ça je crois je suis parti un peu dans
ton style
ça sort d'où ça alors c'est bizarre on
l'a pas vu depuis une petite demi-heure
une petite heure cette partie
effectivement il s'est passé des choses
[Musique]
mais il choppe aussi maintenant une
rupture en Descartes parce que
tranquillement la cavalue 2
B3
pour D1
et il joue G4 tu vois en fait c'est une
position qui est fermée c'est malin ce
qui fait parce que tu vois il a donné
volontairement au début de partie son
fou contre le cavalier ici on sait que
la paire de fou est très forte dans les
positions ouvertes les Noirs possèdent
la paire de fou et du coup les blancs ce
qu'ils font qui vont essayer de voir une
position fermée pour jouer contre les
fous de Wesley
il est en train de faire une partie de
boa constrictor le Magnus et c'est on
sait que c'est sa spécialité lui il
adore grindé des tout petits avantages
pendant des heures et des heures et là
il est en train d'avoir une position qui
s'y à merveille à sa paire de cavaliers
finalement on peut imaginer un H5 puis
un cavalier qui peut venir après en M5
qui peut qui peut être perdu à la paire
de fou qui pourrait contrôler ses pions
là ça peut faire un petit peu peur donc
faire attention à ça mais sinon ça a
l'air franchement assez intéressant pour
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien les blancs
j'aime bien votre position
tu vois on pensait que la rupture elle
allait se faire en Décathlon F4 et bien
finalement il n'a aucun des deux et elle
va se placer en H6
noir à l'aile dame il a intérêt à
arriver assez vite finalement pour
répondre à Simon qui nous demande en
combien de temps c'est les championnats
du monde c'est à peu près des cadences
similaires avec championnats du monde de
parties classiques ce qu'on appelle la
partie classique il existe aussi les
parties rapides qui se jouent en environ
une demi-heure entre 20 minutes et une
demi-heure par joueur et il existe bien
sûr le Blitz où on a beaucoup moins de
temps et il y a des championnats du
monde dans toutes ces cadences là c'est
un tournoi de de partie classique
donc les joueurs ont deux heures chacun
pour jouer l'intégralité de leur coût et
à partir du 40e coup ils auront un
rajout de 10 secondes par coup un
incrément on appelle ça
plus rapide plus lente je sais pas ce
que je ne peux comprendre
j'aurais dit que classique souffle
que ça généralement on 40ème coup tu as
souvent des rajouts d'une demi-heure
encore tu vois et dans ce tournoi tu as
une demi-heure de rajout au 40e coup
mais en plus de ça tu as 30 secondes
d'ajout à chaque coup alors que là on va
se passer
pour moi et ben tu as pas de rajout de
temps garantie elle t'a vu 10 secondes
par coup qui sont à l'hôtel mais 0 temps
bonus donc c'est une partie classique
mais assez rapide par rapport à ce qu'on
a vu comme d'hab
c'est vrai
donc ça ça allait un petit peu le le
parti classiques plutôt lentes aux
parties un peu plus rapide donc c'est un
petit peu moitié-moitié et je trouve pas
assez cool en tout cas moi j'aime bien
les pas les cadences accélère un petit
peu tu vois c'est
intéressant
on aura un Armageddon ça en vous le
rappelle entre chaque joueur qui auront
fait partie nul il y aura une partie où
les Noirs ont 7 minutes les blancs 10
minutes et en cas de nul les Noirs
s'octroi un petit point bonus un demi
point bonus et le plan de Magnus il est
super intéressant là sur le sur les rois
avec sa prise d'espace mais l'ordinateur
a une petite préférence pour les Noirs
ça vaut la peine d'être signalé quand
même mais je pense que Magnus n'en a
cure lui ce qu'il veut c'est un plan à
long terme mettre de la pression sur
Wesley lui faire faire une erreur
et je pense qu'il a trouvé la position
parfaite pour ça
un confessionnal là oh d'une partie qui
se joue en direct
[Musique]
par contre je crois pourquoi je l'ai en
deux fois
est-ce que c'est pas en norvégien
non
c'est pas norvégien alors c'est parti tu
me dis mais comme j'ai deux vidéos il
est possible que
[Musique]
le format ça va peut-être aller longue
histoire
[Musique]
et tu me traduire
à partir sur la scène
professionnelle
[Musique]
je ne sais quoi et en effet
il nous en a fait une belle encore là
il a envoyé des variantes 16 coups je
suis désolé je vais pas vous les
retranscrire j'en suis incapable il a
dit qu'après après dame B8 pour lui fou
B1 était sans doute pas le meilleur coup
pour Google il a vu un je ne sais quoi
en français dans le texte un je ne sais
quoi pour pour les blancs et je pense
qu'il pensait quelque part à des coups
avec cavalier G5 des idées cavaliers G5
ou peut-être H4 il a pas trop aimé
l'idée fou B1 et il dit qu'il est pas
loin d'égaliser il trouve aussi qu'en
Blitz il sent pas très bon parce qu'il
est plus streamer maintenant que que
vraiment joueur et ça lui a fait faire
des décisions vraiment très moyennes
donc
[Musique]
il a l'air super détendu ce qui est
assez rare de voir Nakamura comme ça
c'est assez agréable mais il est pas
temps super confiant parce qu'ils se
sent un peu toujours un peu moins bien
dans cette position
ok beaucoup de respect pour le jeune
goûter en tout cas ok
j'ai vu trois minutes c'est pour savoir
que je l'avais en deux fois et
ah ouais là il est super bavard en fait
il a il a pris cette habitude de de
streamer
encore une fois tous ces petites
confessions et ben ça nous a ça ça donne
du contenu un peu pour le stream pour
des vidéos pour plein de choses donc je
pense que il est aussi content de le
faire
c'est un vrai créateur de contenu
maintenant et depuis que a joué Caval le
5 comme on peut le voir qui était un
coup
[Musique]
qui avait vraiment de la valeur il a
joué de la B7 et il attaque le pion G2
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors on a deux
coups qui sont quand même candidats
je me mets en face du roi adverse
défoncé deux
après pour voir peut-être que il y a des
choses qui peuvent arriver aussi encore
une fois il y a du cavalier B3 qui peut
toujours arriver même eu pour changer
les pièces je passe sur ta place soit
effective
dommage 5 je pensais aussi et même au
pire des cas il y a des varanes de nulle
tu sais avec G6 et du cavalier plongée 6
ça c'est le truc qui peuvent peut-être
marcher donc le sacrif c'est le double
sacrifice avec à chaque perpétuel
peut-être le problème c'est que je
dépendra je sais dans quelques jours
dans l'idée j'aurais voulu faire une nul
c'est pas une idée ça serait trop passif
F3 non c'est possible
de
tuer un peu fou des cinq mais F3 F6 et
on le remet où ce cavalier maintenant
je peux venir ici ici ouais c'est ça
qu'un jour
6 parce que quand tu joues F6 quand même
et ben tu as fait aussi les cases
blanches donc
il donne il donne G2 attention il donne
G2 hyper raciste mais après j'ai un pion
passé aussi maintenant que le pion assez
disparu il faut faire attention mais je
pense qu'il a dû imaginer que que le roi
était pas vraiment de difficulté par
exemple
G4 est aussi une possibilité je peux
manger de large pour manger ici
c'est un peu passé ici j'ai la colonne
j'ai je pourrais éventuellement un jour
exercer une pression avec une tourangère
mais c'est vrai que donner le plonge à
deux pas de confiance
[Musique]
a trouvé le meilleur coup des deux
Caval dessin évidemment qui gagne un
tempo important
et donc il y aura Patrice on fous en D8
en fait
nous dire Beck
ett c'était ton idée c'était de faire
des seins qui l'a pas fait tout de suite
il a d'abord inséré un petit fou des
deux
maintenant que demande ça fait quand
même pas plaisir j'ai l'impression tu
vois cavalier E4 qui menace cavaler des
six la foube aussi et une grosse
pression conjuguée là sur la case 7
c'est très chiant ce roi au centre là
j'ai envie de dire que Paris
superposition il fait sa game il fait
clairement sa game le norvégien
NES au pire du pire
et il y a peut-être même des idées avec
C5 D6 c'est 5 D6 bah moi j'ai coupé 4
hein
ça a l'air très fort ouais
j'ai envie de dire
[Musique]
belle surprise de tournoi qui est en
face de face Abdou il pouvait pas la
mettre en C7 plutôt la dame
Abdou pour au moins avoir des menaces
tactiques
en fait non non
ça va commencer à chauffer
on n'a pas encore eu de pause depuis le
début du tournoi et puis on se revoit
pendant ce temps donc restez connecté on
va vous montrer un petit peu les pubs de
cheesecom ainsi que
ainsi que les ouvrez les parties aussi
ouvert on a des
overlays qui sont très sympas donc donc
voilà en tout cas je vous dis à tout de
suite merci encore de nous suivre restez
là à toute rester en ligne
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les titles Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chase.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
tusset.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour avec Antoine
pour sa deuxième partie de la deuxième
ronde ouais ça va commencer à
s'accélérer là ah oui complètement
alors tout de suite star et qui dit non
non pas de diagonale pour vous monsieur
en bas je vous envoie F4 rentrez chez
vous c'est ce qu'a fait chute
donc ça le mérite de laisser la tour
ouverte soit
sur la colonne de foot j'essaie de base
et donc on a provoqué aussi F4 il peut
aussi être une bonne nouvelle pour les
noirs des fois on a du cavalier 3 pour
expliquer ce noir
il y a un écho j'ai rien changé c'est
magnifique on a touché à rien a priori
les coachs qui nous deux
c'est magnifique je l'ai touché à rien
et ciel bleu qui nous dit de manière
assez
juste de cette offre à rater son
d'ouverture c'est tout à fait exact je
pense pas on y réfléchit tout à l'heure
que le B4 de Tari ah c'était chez
nounours les coups tu nous as fait peur
nounours
ouais donc je pense pas que c'était une
prépa les détails parce que ça me semble
tellement impossible de leur préparer
cette ligne là qui est si obscure qui
n'avait jamais été joué le 7 tours G8
c'est une nouveauté de la part de donc à
moins d'avoir des superbes espions je ne
vois pas comment c'est possible bon il a
joué ses 5 c'est évident et je vous
décide non je pense juste que que c'est
un truc qu'il avait déjà regardé avant
une fois et que ben voilà ou peut-être
qu'il avait regardé cette idée contre un
tour G8 pas forcément à ce moment là
des idées comme ça des idées avec B4
globalement aux échecs on peut toujours
retomber sur ses pattes dans certaines
positions tu as une partie amateur si
elle veut oui j'ai regardé que dans la
base des maîtres effectivement
ok donc c'est ça qu'on a ce qui avait
des six quand même d'ailleurs il aurait
pu faire des savants
est-il pas déjà des facto de roquet des
roquets puisque
quand rock là
et puis maintenant mon roi il est mieux
en fait en F8 quand et 8 où il était
envisagé
non maintenant avec ces cinq moi ça
menacer un cavalier 6 qui avait le
Condes suite c'est 6 par exemple genre
de coups qui deviennent assez
intéressant on va manger un pion on va
mettre un pion en C6
j'ai aussi 10 ce qui est intéressant
et là peut-être même peut-être même des
idées avec cavale des 6 ca va le prendre
B7 puis c'est 6
roi F8 Caval prendre B7 et après
qu'importe la réaction des Noirs je
t'envoie ça 6 bah voilà c'est ça il se
fait un truc comme ça
sûrement une idée de ce type là pourrait
arriver voilà ça commence c'est
absolument terrifiant à 5 aussi ça a
l'air dur
donc c'est 5 en tout cas contrôle il
reste 36 minutes pour que le 22 coups
à pendule
direct à côté il y avait des trois en
face un cata qu'elle a tout à 8 quand
même mais qui n'a pas joué là je vois
mais
T3 ça peut être une idée peut-être qu'on
commence par tour B1 déjà pour s'enlever
de ces idées de Détroit sur des trois on
pourra juste prendre le pion
des trois c'est pas forcément aussi une
grosse menace non plus
je sais pas forcément envie de donner la
tour mais pour expliquer un peu que ce
serait pas grave pour les pour le moment
je pense parce que
tout simplement les cases noires des
Noirs sont très faibles et je pourrais
très vite venir sur le case noire et là
c'est plein plein
ça fait aussi ça fait baissait vraiment
en prise ah oui non mais là pour bien
c'est un coup après en plus là par
rapport à ce que je viens de dire il y a
beaucoup des quatre sites qui posent des
problèmes
donc non ton bien c'est un coup profil
peut-être sur D3
et l'apprendre de fou là ça va accentuer
dans sa on est après roi F8 donc cette
Caravan très haut blanc et je pense tu
auras bien
comment tu défends B7
si tu dois vraiment jouer tour B8 ces
catastrophique et le jeu actif des Noirs
je vois plus trop là
l'ordinateur qui la jauge qui semble
conserver pas mal d'équilibres mais
alors là
pour un humain même là vous autora que
tu as pas être très content de sa
position non
il a bien conscience que ça a glissé
peut-être un peu qu'on a pas vu depuis
[Musique]
il a réussi à avoir une production notre
data qui a l'air pas mal du tout
[Musique]
ouais on l'avait on l'avait quitté à
Tours 5 il a choisi pas attaquer cette
tour tout de suite
mais il a mis la dame à manger 300 aussi
attendez
alors
donc oui
on s'est arrêté à Tourcoing F5 et on
avait des dames B1 il a joué ou D1 il va
ramener la le fou ici peut-être même en
E4 peut-être on vis-à-vis et même taper
sur H7 avec les pièces et la paire de
fou c'est intéressant
parce que c'est
c'est pas non plus enfin si c'est quand
même un point un pion d'écart pour
l'ordinateur là il a il annoncé - 0,8
pour les noirs et là il annonce plus 0,7
pour les blancs donc oui c'est quand
même à leur niveau c'est ce qu'on
appelle une gaffe mais tout de suite
elle est résa qui fait fouger 5 et c'est
à nouveau égal d'après l'ordinateur
aurait pu rater ici notre ami Mohamed
Yara pour avoir jeu cavaler des cinq
alors cavalier prend des cinq ça c'est
le début des négociations
mais c'est pas la suite
c'est prendre
par exemple
pour les
F4 ou C7
moi je te fais tellement confiance
[Rires]
[Musique]
il y a ça aussi en l'air
donc faut faire attention j'ai la cam
des pièces
défends là
H6 probablement votre jouet
est-ce qu'on prévoit pas un coup de
style
je suis pas sûr mais je pensais à me 4
si tu
tomate mais
c'est filou mais est-ce que ça m'a tué
non bah je sais pas je pense
[Musique]
éventuellement dans le cadre tourin etc
et il y a eu H6 je pense qu'on va voir
tous les deux
ouais ça paraît logique et ça menace
presque canal prendre des 5 non c'est
pas une menace tactique
non non
alors
il n'aime pas du tout ça la chose n'aime
pas
dans cette position on va peut-être
aller tranquille un peu la jauge parce
que là
ouais c'est même pour les joueurs oui
c'est clairement
envisager une seule seconde de roi je
pense non
même si bon bah ça a l'air logique
et qu'on voit qu'on comprend que
peut-être que ouais on s'enlève des
dames prends des quatre échecs
par rapport à la vente qu'on a vu avant
que dame 4
c'est la même ligne sauf que maintenant
tu as pu échec et ça
c'est vrai mais bon comment je
mais bon ça a l'air maintenant
c'est chaud c'est chaud moi un peu ce
qui va se passer est-ce qu'on est parti
intéressantes à avoir la caisse espace
parents-chose tout à l'heure
[Musique]
celle de carwana c'est intéressant celle
de karwan aguerri parce que il a fait il
a mélangé les deux plans dont on parlait
tout à l'heure à nigéri il a fait petit
rock et il a aussi joué avec 4 h 5
on va un peu intéressante
pour les Noirs ça a été joué
on empêche les trois
et ici de la part d'Aniche
bon c'est pas un bon coup
des deux qui était une réelle menace et
à Punk est tombé le pion à trois
dans les coûts qui viennent là les Noirs
commencent à tout simplement prendre
l'avantage parce qu'à trois Tombois en
force
comme ceci et le pion A5 devient un beau
passeur
il fait une partie modèle le Fabiano là
pour l'instant c'est
c'est son tournoi
alors est-ce qu'on a envie de faire H5
pour empêcher le cavalier enfin pour
empêcher le pion h de déloger le
cavalier
où est-ce qu'on commence tout simplement
à pousser les pions passés sont faits
pour être poussés c'est ce qu'on dit
généralement
et oui si elle brûle les pollens ils
sont partout le rhume des foins
malheureusement
alors
donc H4 bon bah écoute les noirs sont
très bien la seule chance d'être une des
seules chances pratiques
pour pour
le reposer un jour
ouais parce que son histoire sur le roi
là ça n'avance pas ça n'avance pas dur
il faut prendre
mais en plus le même perdu un jour
donc à voir à voir mais j'aime beaucoup
la prochaine sa vie alors Fabi qui a eu
quand même une année 2022 assez mauvaise
en termes de résultats et de placement
et d'eau il a perdu à peu près 50 points
hello en 2002 puis surtout il s'est fait
voler aux candidat quand même ça je
pense qu'on peut le dire
au candidat ah ouais c'est un peu fait
voler quand même
je sais plus ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la dernière ronde
on ne savait pas encore que Magnus il
arrêtait donc il y avait que la première
place qui comptait et
Fabiano et carou se sont envoyés en
l'air à fond à la dernière ils ont perdu
tous les deux leurs parties et Ding a
récupéré la deuxième place dans tout le
monde se fit puisque deuxième place de
candidats d'importance et finalement
c'est digne qui s'est retrouvé qualifié
en vertu de du forfait de Magnus quoi
alors wanna il avait juste à tirer sa
petite nulle ce qu'il aurait pu faire
très simplement vu son niveau et il
aurait fait le match entre dépôt s'il
avait su ça
donc là pour moi c'est c'est vraiment un
vol manifeste mais bon
mais c'est la faute de personne mais bon
moi ça me fait plaisir de devoir famille
revenir sur sur un superpendant comme
celui-là on pour l'instant la romain est
la battu quand même Magnus
et s'il pouvait confirmer encore dans ce
tournoi avec d'autres gains moi ça me
ferait plaisir j'aime beaucoup
carwana j'aime beaucoup ce joueur et
j'aimerais bien le revoir au plus haut
niveau en tout cas donc je te remercie
c'est la classe il y a rien à dire et là
il a une très très bonne pause j'ai
envie de faire à 5 allez commence par
dames C6 c'est quoi son idée
généralement je vais mettre en relief la
faiblesse des pièces mineures adverse
c'est vrai qu'elles sont pas terribles
qu'avale 2 qu'est-ce que c'est quel est
son futur peut-être une fois cavale G3
plus qu'à Val F5
quel est son futur je sais pas c'est
bien de mettre là
parfait il n'y arrivera jamais ils
arrivent à virer ton cavalier faire C4
je peux y arriver mais bon faut pas trop
rêver à mon avis ça va être compliqué
Annie je guéri il envoie il envoie H5
pour
enlever ce cavalier là
il va venir recette il y a pas le choix
ou pétant F8 est-ce qu'il a des
meilleurs perspectives F8 D7 F8 et 7
bien sûr
et je commence à taper c'est 5
la position elle est bonne pour la bonne
pour les Noirs ça c'est ça c'est clair
est-ce que tu peux aller voir un petit
peu ce qui se passe ailleurs par exemple
la partie de bookcash contre Nakamura
pas trop trop la suite
donc bon c'est un pion quand même
je vois pas trop pourquoi
heureusement qu'il est là parce que il
voit tous les coups donc tu comprends
j'adore F3 8 x 4 et effectivement
je crois que les noirs sont foutus tu
prends la qualité c'est une qualité
de bon à hors-jeu on voit même je
descends plus tard ouvrir un peu les
colonnes ouvrir un bout de jeu et les
pièces vont être trop fortes pour ta
cavaluer
c'est affreux évidemment
qu'on n'a pas vu aussi notre ami Magnus
alors Magnus qui avait balancé un petit
peu les pions GH on s'est arrêté je
crois ici et sur H4 et 20 saut à je le
plan enfin le loup en tout cas qu'on
avait vu avec
peace food et 6 suivi de C5
ouais c'est auto infligé des pions
isolés maintenant ils sont déconnectés
mais il va essayer de s'en débarrasser
tout de suite là et on voit qu'il va
pousser il va essayer de pousser ses
quatre pour l'instant il attaque le pion
à 4 menace de le gagner donc nous qui
défend un tour des forces passives
la question c'est que se passe-t-il sur
cavaler 4
je tu donnes tout juste peut-être qu'en
fait il a calculé ça
on mange tout je mange là je mange là je
mange là
et il est les blancs sont quand même
assez ouvert le roi il est complètement
à poil moi j'aime bien les Noirs là et
moi j'ai un peu passé qui va avancer ça
a l'air pas mal pour les Noirs en tout
cas
pas trop envie de ça avec les Blancs ça
je comprends bien
donc
tour 1 ça va pas du tout comme tu le
disais derrière avec la stratégie de
Carlsen qui a voulu une stratégie
particulière
un tour B8 alors je sais pas laquelle
pour P2 passer par là pendant que les
Blancs ont quelque chose de l'autre côté
donc
tu l'as dit qu'il traîne une ancien
H6 a priori pour venir
bloquer un peu là est-ce que j'ai autre
chose à faire cavalier G3 et 5 peut être
une idée intéressante
dans ce cas là on fait pas on fait pas
après maintenant qu'on vient de combien
de défendre depuis 1 bah c'est vrai
donc il faut commencer à prendre des
décisions
savoir si je joue
[Musique]
comme C4 pour essayer de tout exploser
au centre
alors c'est
compliqué peut-être qu'il veut
simplement faire tour à B8 cavalier
prend F4
plus on prend F4 vous prend F4 et tour
B4
[Musique]
fois en tension ceci si les blancs
prennent en D6 c'est de remettre la
structure droite et là je leur demande
ok qu'est-ce que tu fais pour ton pion à
4 ok j'ai laissé un pion temporairement
mais mes pièces sont plus actives et
je vais gagner surtout un pion a passé
le jour où tu mangeras ton passage
je mange tu manges je mange là-haut tu
manges je mange avec Madame mange là et
après j'ai quoi comme message à quelle
blanche
ce sont les échecs c'est un jeu résolu
c'est bien connu toutes les
inquiète pas trop pour pour
[Musique]
ni pour le Carsen d'ailleurs s'inquiète
de rien là ouais s'inquiète un peu plus
pour le bon Abdou là c'est sur la table
1 et là c'est fou qu'on aille voir ça
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
chez moi c'est la 2 allez hop
par là-dessus rien de tarié avec les
Blancs il fait une Master Class
l'ordi a changé d'avis brutalement mais
il y a eu tout assez donc on a évoqué
on s'arrête
donc
C6 il y a plein de choses on enlève
aussi de l'Internal du ou donc il y a
plein de choses qui sont intéressantes
des trois menaces je pense ou des quatre
échecs qui met le roi blanc un petit peu
en réseau de maths
il vient échanger les poux
et empêcher surtout le coup d'écart et
là le coup de de dire Beck apparemment
est une grosse gaffe il a envoyé aussi
dans cette position
ta grosse gaffe non c'est une
imprécision
d'après le module
à nous de voir pourquoi
direct sur la colonne
qui est pas mal déjà en fait je peux en
premier regardez échec sur
ben je prends je prends oui et là il y a
plus d'attaque il y a pas d'âme j'ai 7
parce que c'est contrôlé et
effectivement
en fait au final c'est les blancs que le
matin ah mais tape sa race oui c'est ça
ton match il arrive beaucoup trop tard
avec dommage 4
et comment tu vas faire
dommage apparemment
[Musique]
je ferai pas
peut-être sympa comme tout ça
oui mais j'ai quand même plus fort
voilà
il est toujours oui je préfère défendre
le match en m'attend moi que en cachant
et en courant quoi clairement mais on
peut on peut imaginer que nos dire Beck
jouera pas cette variante donc il va
sans doute jouer un truc plus solide et
perdre le pion des trois enfin de
variante clairement
c'est hyper chaud matériellement
surprise en dessin qu'est-ce qui se
passe
aussi peut-être alors
[Musique]
cette cavale des 6 ouais je pense que
plein de garçons
[Musique]
j'avais un peu peur du pion des mais il
devrait être contrôlé assez facilement
non tu peux pas manger là tu peux pas
faire dommage 4
si tu prends là ça en fait ça a l'air
c'est 6 ça a l'air très dangereux alors
il y a
l'ordi trouver un truc qui sauve un peu
je te laisse y réfléchir moi je l'ai vu
[Rires]
et on vous laisse y réfléchir dans le
chat un coup qui sauve un tout petit peu
la situation
qui a déclaré aux grandes chasseurs de
Bucarest que l'ordi dit 0.00 si souvent
que c'est devenu difficile de s'en
servir c'est vrai que maintenant il va
tellement loin stock fish 15 là que il
te trouve des nuls de l'espace dans
toutes les positions c'est un peu c'est
parfois un peu décevant
ouais c'est moi
faut prendre ces trois pour se sauver un
peu
j'ai pas regardé la suite
elle comprend
là je dois manger parce que
la logique oui c'est plus logique
c'est 5 qui doit commencer à faire mal
et puis on va récupérer puis on des
trois minima ça fera
au pire on met une pièce assez simple on
interpose dans ces cinq peut-être parce
que là il y a F5 après qui avait l'après
fois
peut-être c'est chaud je sais pas ouais
ouais non mais c'est pour sauver pour
sauver sa peau les Noirs là il peut
jouer n'importe quoi en fait quelque
part
prometteur pour pour Paris il faut quand
même deux sortes une super défense
il s'est mis il s'est mis dans la panade
Abdou il a jamais été vraiment bien dans
cette partie
elle a pas bien marché c'est lui qui a
été surpris alors que c'est lui qui
avait amené la prépa amusante
et là il est en train de se faire
marcher dessus c'est ça avance ça avance
ça avance côté blanc
du coup j'essaie dans le début
ouais et c'est sûr qu'il a réfléchi à ce
coup-là qu'il a vu ça lui non
il y a encore 15 coups à faire pour
arriver à l'incrément de 10 secondes
donc
il peut trembler il peut trembler mais
on va voir
il s'est passé un truc un peu ouf
je suis
un F5 de jouer
et F5 c'est un coup assez chaud là
F5
c'est assez moche comme cou c'est très
bizarre
et pourquoi vous cache revient en
arrière sur
cavalier est très bien maintenant qu'il
est sur une case forte
sur le site
alors ici il va aussi dépendre
à attaquer G2 avec son F5 en fait parce
que
l'idée de ciel bleu tout à l'heure avec
F3 et suivi de fou 4 pour faire un
filtre
G2 il y a plus F3 fois
4 non mais en fait faut prendre
mais ça c'est pas un peu une menace
tactique nulle de la part du carreau
pour te prendre G2 enfin c'est
oui non ça a l'air moi c'est un coup je
vois qui m'a l'air très suspect F5
et donc faut voir un peu c'est vrai que
là
si je vais couper ça
on reprend les du pions on était très
content de cette position avec la perte
de foot je pense ouais
en B6 comment est-ce que je l'améliore
le rêve des blancs c'est bien sûr j'ai
changé des fous pour ma ta pression
aussi
cavalier ici
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait essayer de
faire ici c'est pas simple première
peut-être que oui mais je reprends on
sait pas trop comment juger cette
position Caval G5 est un couple alors là
il peut de nouveau manger là mais je
mange là
c'est chaud je pense pas qu'il je pense
que le fond noir doit rester en baisse
encore
ça excuse vraiment je me lasse de manger
là
on aura du cavale C5 inter ouais ou du
coup pour F5 c'est vrai que
ça reste une idée
[Musique]
après il y a aussi du Fou E5 qui a l'air
intéressant enfin fullition
pour bouger enfin pour attaquer la tour
et essayer d'avoir des cases être venu
ici
voilà mais ça a l'air très suspect ce
qu'il fait mais écoute on n'a pas encore
trouvé vraiment de de solution contre
son F5
mais c'est vrai que c'est un coup qui
est qui est très très bizarre sur Caval
G5 les noirs peuvent juste défendre
passivement avec peut-être Dame des 7 et
ensuite ils feront H6 et finalement ça
t'a pas avancé à grand chose en double
sur la colonne ciel bleu oui mais
comment je fais dur à faire
tout de suite
je peux donner les caves blanches
peut-être que sur ça
pas sûr d'avoir assez
je pense pas que j'aurai assez mais
j'ai pas d'autres cases pour doubler en
fait
à part C5 mais il y aura un fou B6
tout de suite
il y en a pas du tout envie de laisser
les noirs et changer se fout de casse
noir surtout contre une tour évidemment
non non
je sais pas comment on continue en tout
cas dans une grande réflexion là avec
les mains sur sa tête il est mieux je
dirais moi j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
0,50 donc c'est c'est quoi le coup qui
propose alors il propose pour les il
propose fouder 6 comme tu as comme tu as
parlé comme tu as envisagé tout à
l'heure
c'est trop bizarre alors en fait surtout
prends un F5 parce qu'il y a un visa
et peut-être le touriste c'est le seul
coup
c'est quoi la suite
j'ai trois à la mais c'est la petite
turbine tu vois de chaise.com donc c'est
vite dépassé quand même
c'est très très vite et passer ce genre
d'ordi
c'est souvent un peu décevant et là je
peux pas faire tourner la je peux pas
faire tourner l'ordi de chez moi ok
ok bon en tout cas une position qui est
assez intéressante assez prometteuse
c'était laquelle c'était excuse-moi
c'était la 2 je vais vous mettre les
caméras sur les joueurs vous allez les
voir en direct
voilà attends
c'est 5 raté
de la part du joueur norvégien
sur damage 4 l'échec c'était dame B4 et
dame C5 ça marche pas pareil
je comprends pas pourquoi pour l'instant
je comprends pas la différence profonde
entre ces deux coups
peut-être que la
défense d'un B2 échec G3
je bouge et tu fais G3 attaque la dame
et je m'en là je défends le maths
[Musique]
incroyable et donc en fait avec son dab
c'est 5 il a pas la retour sur la
deuxième c'est de est occuper d'un prix
de 3 et maintenant
la partie elle peut tourner
ça peut carrément tourner ça peut faire
des perpettes aussi peut-être les Noirs
là ils ont
il y a du
genre ils sont toujours une pièce en
prise ils ont joué cette séquence à la
vitesse de la lumière Tariq qui aurait
mieux fait de réfléchir un peu plus perf
4 là
je préférer chaque aussi manger ici
c'est chaud
il me permet de défendre
et de continuer à pousser mon pion et là
si je le fais et chaque fois là et
chaque il faut que j'aille où là madame
contrôle le cas ici
c'est chaud
les deux les deux joueurs peuvent gagner
c'est facile franchement je pense que si
je
pense que je peux je pense que je peux
être le meilleur joueur du monde non non
non
je pense qu'avec une vraie jaune je peux
être pas mal
c'est dommage parce que le plan avec
Dame B2 pour défendre par G3
il est
oui c'était ça évidemment la défense
stoule tu l'as bien vu ça il doit le
voir rien de Tariq quand même 2651 bah
si tout me vois
non mais sans déconner et après il l'a
joué il a joué son truc en 35 secondes
donc en fait il commence à stresser avec
le temps là il est dans son Armageddon
mais c'est vrai que franchement
franchement ça se trouve moi en fait
j'ai vu la jauge qui m'a dit que c'était
que c'était ça et pas que c'était MBK
je cherchais pourquoi c'était pas bon et
en fait c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé assez
facilement ça et ça mais bon je suis pas
en partie c'est pas pareil
tu joues pas un top 15 mondial et enfin
évidemment c'est pas pareil et il s'est
laissé déborder là rien de tard
je me vois pas à 2006 2007 avec une
jauge quand même
parce que
entre 150 peut-être une jauge plus tu es
fort plus ça va te profiter je pense oui
mais bon
imagine que deux points
j'avoue que tu me files une jauge dans
mes parties ça me fait gagner rien que
dalle
quand même je pense je suis pas sûr tu
sais que ton adversaire
[Musique]
donc
c'est la partie et
3e
on n'est pas là pour faire nul hein
quand même j'imagine ici
pour continuer à jouer et derrière il y
a pas d'échec qui suivent
il y a toujours une pièce en prise côté
noire
les blancs sont archi gagnants en fait
mais j'adore se poser cette position
alors que les deux les deux rois sont à
poil j'aime beaucoup ce genre de
position
et bon c'est très chaud pour les deux
joueurs
qui a été raté par les deux joueurs là
tu t'avances il est tout à fait possible
que tout soit temps il les vues avec MBK
c'est chaud cette partie et sur roi L2
qu'est-ce qui va jouer alors il faut il
faut quand même sortir de là peut-être
je mange je fais pour C8
tu as le droit de faire ça de prendre un
dessin
tu prends là tu prends la
c'est la guerre que je te propose
[Rires]
c'est pas mal F2
[Musique]
6 pour continuer à défendre le fou pour
tour des
8 doit être pas mal sur T8 terminale en
fait maintenant tu prends ma dame
bon c'est très chaud ouais c'est truc de
fou c'est on n'aura pas cette pause sur
l'échiquier je pense
oui prise de sang que ça c'est probable
après si c'est trop trop trop compliqué
Ariane tari est quand même capable de
jouer ici
tu penses qu'il va se dégonfler c'est
vrai que ça fait un bout de temps qui
réfléchit
un quart d'heure pour jouer du coup
enfin non pas pour jouer du coup pour
jouer toute la partie
juste il récupère un petit incrément
après ouais donc c'est pas ouf
il est pas comme sur les parties ou aux
40e comme un phare dans la nuit tu vois
le rajout de 30 minutes non quand même
là il a pas il y aura pas de rajout il y
aura un petit incrément pour essayer de
survivre ah ouais non à mon avis il va
se débrouiller
je pense qu'il va jouer
parce que la partie la plus grande voir
elle a l'air beaucoup trop compliqué
et
avec peu de temps la pendu en plus très
très bon tactique
si il sent que ça a pas un risque de le
rejoindre et ceci fait moi j'ai est-ce
cap d'où peut changer
très vicieux là de jouer pour le gain
là-dedans
[Musique]
il peut le faire
un coup droit
quand même avec du DAB 7 3
peut-être il y a du damset 3 maintenant
et dans cette
c'est très chaud je vois pas
[Musique]
moi je pense qu'il va jouer quand même
il sait jouer c'est jouer monsieur
orientari
[Musique]
voilà il montre qu'il est là quand même
il est pas venu pour cueillir les
pâquerettes il lui reste 14 minutes et
il est là il joue pour gagner contre
contre
pièces quand même ça peut aller mieux
simplement mais j'ai un pion là ça va
quoi mais
tu peux gagner la partie instante
je pense qu'il a dû faire match nul et
ça a fait nul on peut aller voir si tu
veux ce qui s'est passé on aura
l'Armageddon j'imagine tu as environ un
quart d'heure j'attends de voir les
infos que je slack donc il a bien fait
il a fait mon plan ouais
ce qui s'est passé on t'arrêter à peu
près par là et vu qu'elle va les prendre
pour B8 C4 et le couper le four adverse
pour B4 cavalier B1 et assurer le
cavalier en C3 pour venir
dame C2
et Wesley qui a gagné son pion et qu'a
proposé nul il y a un peu plus quand
même pour pour Wesley mais ce fou c'est
un groupe qui ont le très clair
ouais mais bon
ah ouais non mais c'est de la
pleutreerie tout à fait logique
donc nul assez
normal
est-ce que tu vas aller voir un peu un
joueur qui dirige il se passe des choses
là ah Thierry contre
kerwana c'est la partie numéro 4
la belle chatte qu'il a guéri tout d'un
coup quand même
on va voir un peu ce qui s'est passé
on disait qu'il avait une mauvaise pose
il fallait faire quelque chose
alors c'est clair que si il joue pas ça
j'ai envie de dire que tu vas faire Dame
des 8 c'est provoquer l'échange des
tours pour gagner la colonne D et après
tu as un pion de plus c'est sur le long
terme tu vois quand même réussir à
peut-être rentrer ta dame sur des deux
par exemple peut-être gagner quoi
tu es mal il faut il faut faire quelque
chose il faut réagir et après la prise
mais là je me sens déjà qui bouge le fou
et qui peut manger ces quatre et bah
écoute c'est chaud concrètement c'est ça
devient très chiant à jouer pour le
moment
j'étais vraiment malin comme idée pour
se débarrasser de cette faiblesse du
pion doublée le pont C5 qui était tout à
l'heure très faible il devient très fort
pour la pièce ouais c'est très peu mais
quel pion quel quel avancée centrale
quoi grosses inventé qui peut qui peut
arriver
donc
chaud chaud je vois pas trop
des cinq sens c'est une grosse menace
alors dis qu'il nous demande la jauge
qui le dit du 0.00 bien sûr comme d'hab
mais la menace T5 c'est vrai qu'elle est
elle est ultra chiante est-ce qu'on rend
le matos
même dans la douche
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
seulement le matériel même pas sûr là y
20h30
OK
ouais il envoie B5
ok donc la pièce
d'accord
tu manges mais imaginons un truc comme
ça
c'est
ça reste en tout cas jouable si je joue
pas des 5 par manger là mais après
qu'elle va les prendre je pense que
pas que ça ça a été 5 en fait
de bouger sa tour et de garder sa pièce
de plus en fait
prise en place
non non je veux dire les Noirs menacent
de leur tour au prochain
la position où on est actuellement il
menace
comme ça
pratique pour la banque
on se pratique en tout cas monstrueux de
la part de gris qui sait qui démarre et
qui doit réagir à tout prix et tu vois
les ressources qu'ils ont dans la
position c'est
super impressionnant et j'ai
l'impression que le P5 est vraiment fait
je voudrais peut-être qu'on aille voir à
l'ireza là apparemment il est en
difficulté face à lazeri
allumé on va on va aller voir ça de
suite
en fait
on s'est arrêté à un damage
B4 où j'ai 6 tours F6
et toutes les pièces tours alors c'est
ça qu'apparemment c'est pas un bon coup
non de la part de
lui préférait dame D8
dame D8 ramener des pièces j'imagine
[Musique]
et une idée alors c'est simple pourquoi
c'est pas bon d'être là ça a l'air hyper
logique mais c'est vrai que maintenant
prise ça a gagné un pion pour les pour
les blancs quand même
est-ce qu'il a raté
la tempête qu'il avait pensé
avoir un cavalier 2 un truc du style
marché ça marche très bien et sur
cavalier 2
là
c'est compliqué hein
c'est hyper compliqué mais c'est des
positions que Cali raisin il aime
beaucoup ouais mais c'est la jauge qui
nous trompe encore avec ses 0,0 en fait
c'est super compliqué il y a pas de 0
il va se passer des trucs
les deux joueurs adorent ces positions
là il peut se passer encore un tas de
trucs
tout à l'heure pour lui tout à l'heure
mais je suis 1800 hello à peu près un
peu plus vide
donc c'est ça ok ben écoute
c'est une partie qui part un petit peu
en cacahuète donc 8h30 on aura la
l'Armageddon de Magnus
Ariane tari ça a joué un petit peu
de Paris ça a joué ah oui on n'a pas
joué la ils sont pas dans la partie
qu'on a enfin dans la lune que tu avais
proposé alors il a bien pris en DS5 il a
fait
et c'est chaud à tout prix
va tomber ah oui le pion est cloué
maintenant non
c'est complètement
je comprends pas
[Musique]
ok mais si je fais juste 3D d'eux et je
me carapate tu vas manger
là donc ça m'a l'air quand même
pas forcément notre idéal tu vois
il se passe tellement de choses ici
ouais
vraiment gagnant donc Ariane Tariq qui a
réussi à se noyer dans ses propres
complications
[Musique]
ces deux pions waouh
alors celle-là elle va la trouver raide
à mon avis
ça va lui rester en travers de la gorge
à trouver j'ai envie de dire la prioca
direct ce qui est cloué il peut pas
manger de fou c'est interdit de manger
ici
mais oui voilà d'un prince te reprend
ensuite ton concept et c'est un gros
avantage
[Musique]
sang froid de nos derbeek
mais je suis pas sûr que il leur fera
l'ouverture je crois qu'il leur fera
plus
en tout cas maintenant il est grillé
mais ouais mais bon les gens
ils vont voir ils vont regarder
la mémoire qu'ils ont enfin ça sera plus
joué c'est sûr c'est griller maintenant
non c'est sûr que c'est et Mala qui est
content parce que mala il va il va faire
le plein de de points de chaîne il va se
faire sur le dos de de you mais
alors on a goût cache qui a qui a joué
on peut aller voir un peu buka si tu
veux
ou qu'est-ce qui est ici
il s'est passé des choses dans la partie
on s'est arrêté à un ouais
donc c'est pas trop quoi jouer nous même
cavaler B3 pour C2 parce qu'il va en
fait ramener la tour sur la carte de 2
avec
il a laissé encore le cabinet ici vous
êtes position c'est pas forcément
géniale à cause de bon je peux manger là
mais il y a aussi échec d'un promet 3
qui reste une idée
assez intéressante
donc
ici
une menace
thématique parce qu'après tous ces gars
je vais réussir à échanger des coups de
casse blanche et après les gens se fout
de 15 branche c'est bien c'est vrai que
la structure de noir
est un peu en PLS
je te peux te proposer peut-être Cavala
5 mais tu veux maintenant tu vas t'en
paraître tout simplement du fout des
cinq en fait
comme tour C8
maintenant
ah maintenant ici ouais pour empêcher
fou ces quatre et essayer de gagner la
colonne ou la colonne C ça changeait
qu'on cavalier B3 elle est quand même
venue ici pour
contrôler cette case là et empêcher les
blancs de doubler mais moi je vois bien
un truc comme ça
est-ce que j'ai pas un faucontre
F peut-être simplement ouais et on met
en lumière là la faiblesse tu peux aussi
admettons que les noirs
[Musique]
mais on n'y est pas du tout du tout du
tout et d'ailleurs s'il y a eu il y a eu
des échanges massifs en C8 à l'instant
il a mangé là-haut il a préféré manger
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qui va jouer il est toujours
un peu mieux avec les Blancs il peut y
avoir des menaces de fou pour F5
et pour l'instant il y a toutes les
défendu là
je pense que Naka il a vraiment fait une
partie très solide
et l'impression que Google je suis là
pas obtenu grand chose dans cette partie
et
donc avoir en tout cas la suite de la
partie mais c'est assez calme pour
l'instant je peux voir Aniche
que ça va se liquider assez vite alors
qu'il y a des cas qui était un coup
brillant par l'ordinateur qui était
brillant on les avait laissés sur après
B5 il y a eu prise en passant de la part
du du grand maître hollandais
cavaliers B5
et en fait on se retrouve dans cette
finale où les Noirs ont un pion passé en
a
mais paire de fou en face
et ça niche je le vois bien tenir ça
pendant des siècles
ouais c'est un pion un qui est passé
les blancs de fou il a pas le foot 15 se
voir au pire du pire
un blocus
mais bon après tu as joué à H5 ton roi
il est normalement un peu plus faible
que le mien peut-être qu'un jour j'ai du
cavalier F4 essayer de c'est pas c'est
pas tant
Fabiano a tout à fait le droit de
tourner ça aussi longtemps qu'il le veut
effectivement peut être
c'est pas encore c'est clair
carbonate encore un peu mieux il va
encore essayer de pressé mais c'est vrai
que tu as parlé se dirige un petit peu
vers une nulle je pense
alors que
Paris je crois il est complètement ça
est arrivé il a explosé en plein vol il
s'en voudra longtemps mais alors côté à
l'ireza alors
on s'est arrêté à peu près là
arrêtez ici à Foucault
alors si je prends G4 petite blague
c'est que je vois F6
en fait là si je prends là
juste j'ai bougé mon cavalier il y a
deux pions plus quand même pour
pour
[Musique]
les noirs et ça va gagner je pense et à
la place si je fais tourner 4 ça c'est
marrant
parce que donc sur une case où il y a
pas échec si je veux là là il prend sur
un chèque après une pièce de plus là je
viens ici et là tu as plus d'échec
vraiment on va si tu fais tourner fin
super maintenant
voilà et en fait je vais finir par
perdre du matériel
en la tour ben je bouge madame et si tu
prends madame je mange la tour et je
gagne une qualité donc ton projet 4
n'est pas possible dans la partie il
arrive juste fait 3 et là on peut parler
donc cavalier F6 il peut y avoir un tour
G3
mais je pense même pas grave en fait
[Musique]
technique a priori pour le pour nous
tout ça d'ouverture
c'est Antoine en maître Grand Maître
Antoine
n'importe quoi
[Rires]
alors
tac tac est-ce que on a des parties un
peu alors Fillon on n'est pas allé le
voir tout à l'heure il se passait des
choses ces filles
il y a eu des longs de la colonne A
et d'ailleurs la jauge qui fait du
breakdance un peu là qui saute dans tous
les sens
aime bien les Noirs puis là elle
aimerez-vous bien les blancs piqué
on sait pas trop où il va se fout
re
les deux joueurs ratent actuellement
quelque chose alors on a des papillons
et surprise là
c'était quoi le tout l'ordi adoré dames
en B5 mais c'est vrai
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
elle est pas encore même pas encore
lancer la partie Magnus
donc je peux pas du tout
[Musique]
non j'ai rien encore sur Armageddon
mais dès que ça vient je vous dis
ça va commencer en un instant je pense
partie de Magnus
un magazon
plus d'infos
OK
attends couper ça
bonjour aussi à ceux qui ne suivent sur
sur Youtube pour répondre plus
sérieusement à tout ça parce que c'est
vrai que je me suis pas trop présenté je
m'appelle Antoine moi je travaille pour
comme depuis
7 ans à peu près je travaille au service
au service international donc les textes
en français que que vous retrouvez sur
le site
s'est fait soit par Samir Robin soit par
moi et voilà je fais un petit
remplacement on va dire parce que
souvent tu commentes avec Laurent
Freyssinet avec des grands maîtres comme
ça c'est parti d'ailleurs pour
l'Armageddon
Magnus un peu plus
on se plie ça et si tu veux si tu tu
peux regarder un peu ce qui se passe à
côté si on a des des
coups des trucs qui se passent on fait
ça tu me tiens au courant je regarderai
aussi de ton côté on fait ça je peux pas
trop bouger avec mes écrans
donc Magnus qui a des blancs qui ont
fait la même ouverture et qui changent
un petit peu lors de coup là il a mis le
four en G5 alors il avait joué
différemment
et donc Magnus qui a 10 minutes contre 7
Magnus doit absolument gagner la partie
en cas d'égalité en cas de ma tenue
qui gagnera
la partie
l'espagnol d'échange qui viennent de
jouer mais là cette celle-là est bien
bien différente quand même puisque
Magnus a tout de suite attaqué le centre
avec des quatre Wesley fait grand rock
il met il met une un vis-à-vis qui peut
être intéressant entre le roi entre la
dame blanche et la Tour Noire ça peut
être sympa ça les Noirs ont déjà un bel
avantage après l'ordinateur
après ça il y a un plan comme cavalier
de bloquer ici parce que la prise là il
y a E5 à voir quand même mais je pensais
quand même c'était pas clair je pense
que c'est embêtant
donc
manger là et faire ça il y a plus de
fourchette en 5 c'est un cauchemar de
joueur d'espagnol cette position
tout ce qui pouvait bien se passer pour
les Noirs en train de bien se passer ils
ont un roi totalement en sécurité ils
ont ils vont bientôt avoir les colonnes
à Gégé si tu arrives à les ouvrir
et on forcer les les
et on forcer les Noirs à faire les
blancs à faire des échanges
ouais ouais non ça va être dur est-ce
que c'est 3 pour défendre l'art et
pendant ma 4 peut-être essayer de passer
à l'attaque de l'autre côté j'ai pas de
pièces pour attaquer toutes mes pièces
sont ici
je suis un peu tout seul elle se
bouchonne entre elles en plus les pièces
blanches
très mauvais début très mauvaise entrée
en matière pour Carlson
il a fait ces trois il y a de la
ressource il y a de la ressource
le champion norvégien
Beck juste pour info c'est pour info on
n'est pas obligé de les retourner il a
effectivement joué cavale le 5 cavaliers
et il va convertir très tranquillement
avec ce document de plus voilà c'était
la petite mise au point
et sur l'armage et Dombes
est-ce que vous voulez est-ce que vous
voulez cette scène pour un magasin à
vous proposer est-ce que vous voulez
celle là dites moi dans le chat
que vous préférez est-ce que cette scène
elle est bien pour vous je peux vous
mettre chez qui un peu plus grand si
vous voulez et le mettre un petit peu en
bas ou en haut peut-être
je peux tout faire
mais un truc comme ça tu peux mettre en
haut ça rentrera pas malheureusement
ah c'est pas mal ça comme scène quand
même pour suivre alors Magalon vous
voyez bien entendu je peux mettre sur la
tête de Wesley
on s'en fout de toi
en plus on va pas couper quinzaine
c'est que un peu du mal à mettre plus
grand parce que je vais prendre la place
de Wesley
est-ce qu'il le mérite
allez est-ce que ça vous va comme ça
c'était vraiment filou
magnifique merci à vous pour vos
commentaires
allez
d'ailleurs je pourrais même si vous
voulez changer un moment donné un moment
ce n'est pas il y a d'autres parties qui
se passent ma mère vient d'envoyer le
Caval prend G2 donc on évoqué tout à
l'heure
pardon là
il a envoyé le cavale G2 qu'on évoqué
tout à l'heure
ok bon juste la pose de ma médié
bon vous aurez
un petit spoil juste pour revenir
maintenant sur quinzaine
ouvrant un petit peu fou alors
je coupais 4 et maintenant
ça se passe très très mal pour Magnus
qui qui passe une mauvaise journée
qui va être long pour ma nul ce qui a
perdu hier en classique et maintenant
qu'il y a cette qui traîne quand même
c'est pas chiant
ah la qualité elle est prise hein
il a l'air en PLS
il a pris à cette Magnus il a pris à
cette mais ça c'est la prise des espoir
je pense
quelque chose
c'est une qualité de moi il y a G4 qui
peut arriver aussi attention
[Musique]
pour les noirs
le Magnus qui doit créer quelque chose
c'est maintenant
qu'un cavalier un cavalier c'est
toujours filou c'est toujours piégeur ça
peut faire des choses bah ouais il y a
même un bon là d'imbécile bien sûr on va
on va refuser l'échange d'abord puis
après
dans ma ville tu te cavaliers
ça ça
garde l'échec pour plus tard
dans 5 minutes 58 contre 3 minutes
c'est le cas c'est du chaos jusqu'au 40e
coup ou au 40e coup il y a une seconde
de rajoute pour les devoirs 21e coups
donc il en reste 20 coups à jouer ça
absolument aucun incrément et
j'aime bien
et voilà
il y a même E5 qui joue pour faire le 6
pour aller prendre le pion L6 il y a eu
des cinq l'ordi des tests détestés F6 en
fait si tu regardes le truc il y a que
des coups en rouge
c'est juste des coups d'humains désolé
et le roi qui revient là
perpette
malheureusement prend la nul et Ben
et ben il perd l'armag est donc là on
peut prendre un peu quand même faire la
dame à 8 et pris 6 échecs bon alors il a
joué il a joué à E5 donc sur tourcond
des 5 qui est déjà échec et j'enfile la
tour minimum
3 mais je vais aussi manger des pions je
pense
dans quel ordre comment je fais mais
c'est quoi
si tu arrives à enlever voilà les
réseaux de maths prise F6 pour avoir un
passeur à deux cases de dames mais alors
vas-y jamais piqué
je sens c'est chaud j'ai chaud il est il
sent pas très bien enlever
je pense qu'il fait il est nerveux il
est énervé
tout simplement
ouais c'est pas mal j'espère que vous
appréciez oh là là bague bus qu'est-ce
qu'il est maladroit il a fait tomber
toutes les pièces et il rentre dans
cette variante qu'on vient de voir c'est
à dire qu'il a pris en F6 il pousse tout
de suite F7
[Musique]
un jour de dames
Magnus qui avait une position qui était
très compliqué il y a quelques jours
cavalier
[Musique]
quand même hein
est-ce que ça c'est un coup et tout
reprend des 5 en fin de 20 ans au pire
et c'est ah oui
est-ce que c'est un coup
je défends tout non esthétique
et
prend son temps Magnus
contre 2 3 et il y a des élector à trois
aussi
cavaler prendre un petit tour là il va
faire il a joué lentement il a pas fait
il a pas fini
qui défend avec ses 6 bien sûr
allez où est-ce que tu vas devoir fuir 3
c'est 7 c'est quoi la pointe
je vois pas la pointe il joue les coups
de manière très assurée Michaelson
à tout moment
j'ai tout rêve 3 qui a l'air très sympa
aussi
toi qui a l'air un monstrueux à un prix
prise donc à faire je prends une qualité
la France là pour baisser
[Musique]
tout F3 qui est encore dans l'arène chez
qui est pas mal aussi
il a fait ton rêve froid il est
simplement ce planquer et la fête au F3
ouais il y a trop de bon coup en fait
quand il y a trop de bon coup des fois
on sait plus quoi faire alors là ça va
être mal bientôt peut-être dans ma 3
juste il aura fait un beau travail là
enfilade j'avais même pas vu enfilade ça
va être abandon de saut qui va tendre la
main effectivement waouh c'est une
partie un petit peu stupide j'ai envie
de dire il y avait tout emprise au début
il a fait n'importe quoi mais après il a
fini par par bien jouer
comme ça
on va revenir sur sur une autre scène
cette scène était vraiment pas mal mais
pour le Death Note c'était pas forcément
le mieux enfin
[Musique]
à évaluer ok bon ça reste compliqué à la
place il a joué cavalerons G2 qui n'est
pas bon à cause de tout simplement ça on
ignore
de toute façon ou des cartons là un peu
analysé cette position tout à l'heure
c'était quoi c'était cavaliers 3 on a vu
cette position exactement avec un garçon
de temps et sans l'ouverture de la
colonne on a vu ça
c'est chaud
c'est malheureusement un mauvais coup
mais c'était le coup de stouffe
et on voit que a terminé aussi la partie
je le vois discuter et ça a été un gain
d'absor enfin
à ton truc ah non il allait plus loin
encore il est allé un peu plus loin mais
il a converti de manière très très
c'est une partie complètement folle
c'était la partie de ton âge je pense la
partie à suivre
et à chaque H4 qui prend la case
quand même parce qu'il avait il avait
annulé la prepa adverse et il a fini par
se faire complètement retourné il a raté
un gain honnêtement qu'il aurait dû voir
j'aurais dû voir toi tu rates un comme
ça stouf tu t'en voudrais oh ouais je
pense mais ok tu peux rater mais
bon ouais non je peux rater mais bon moi
je suis une patate quoi
moi je peux le voir mais
je pense que j'ai quand même même moi je
le vois
il y a tellement en fait quand tu as une
pollution avec tellement de possibilités
des fois tu rates les gains qui sont
sympas en fait donc
non oui
[Musique]
je me rappelle
ceux qui me connaissent le savent
je rate des trucs pas mal de trucs
donc ici ben écoute Faby il met la
pression quand même un petit pion qui
avance
et ben écoute
il a trouvé un peu tous les toutes les
idées pour l'embêter le plus longtemps
possible guéri mais le pion de plus bah
il reste il est toujours là dans cette
finale de foot couleur opposée alors je
crois que ah oui alors c'est vrai que
Abdou a gagné donc il faut que je règle
les dettes c'était quoi c'est Paul non
c'était pas Paul c'était quoi l'autre
il y a 5 minutes pour guéri
mais je pense tout la partie qui va
chauffer c'est surtout fil rouge à ma
mère
tout d'un coup se retrouve avec une
position préférentielle et ce cavalier
bah
ce cavalier
on sait pas trop ce qu'il fait le contre
matériel c'est quoi c'est 4 pions chacun
paire de fou côté blanc
j'ai payé les dettes
je crois alors ouais donc on peut
revenir un peu sur Abdou sur firuke plus
rapidement voir gokash voir où il en est
avant de passer sur l'autre
donc là il y a plein de pièces au centre
là
franchement Google qui joue qui joue le
gars à fond il tente des choses ah
j'aime beaucoup comment il joue c'est
la nouvelle génération qui qui veut qui
veut vraiment vraiment pas faire nul et
qui joue pour progresser qui a peur de
personne et
il a joué le avec l'idée bouger Caval G5
H4 qu'on évoqué tout à l'heure il est
venu reprendre la colonne
Ikao a donné la paire de fou non pardon
il a laissé la perte de fou de ma radio
OK
j'ai laissé la paire de fou mais il a
des pièces un peu meilleur alors que
faire de ce cavalier maintenant qui est
attaqué bon cette valeur qui recule
peut-être en H4
c'est pas mal mais attention quelqu'un
de 4
je vois un coup de fou perdre là mais si
je bouge mon cou je peux aussi perdre ça
c'est assez compliqué c'est chaud
il faut prendre et là je prends des
quatre
[Musique]
donc après le après le Caval prend G2
voilà qui fait du smurf la va falloir
qu'on analyse vraiment nous-même parce
que là ça fait n'importe quoi donc après
le Caval prend G2 il y a eu pris C5 il y
a eu d'ams6 il y a eu des 4 4 et logique
et le Cavalo 3 qui était un très mauvais
coup
était mal joué apparemment et il y a eu
tout rêve de cavaler ici tour G2 menace
discrètement un petit matin
à l'ancienne le petit maths alors il y a
quand même dame prend en F3
qui annonce
il y a cette tour qui est en prise
encore alors tout refait on se prend fou
projet 7
dis donc
de transformer les cellules ouais il va
il va ramasser une cale là
[Musique]
F3 qui va tomber c'est hyper compliqué
parce qu'à tout moment en fait tu vois
donc franchement
parfois 4
mais bon il faut s'envoyer 34 parce que
parce que là sur pion j'ai toujours ici
qui va permettre
mon ami
mais après tu peux manger toutes les
qualités mais bon
un camp qui attaque sur les cases
blanches qui attaque sur les cases
noires ça reste très compliqué donc faut
4 ouais c'est un mais H4 alors est-ce
que est-ce que 4 coups brillant de tout
quoi
je pensais pas un truc comme ça derrière
toi ça aurait pu être beau c'est fou
était pas là ça aurait été une fin de
partie juste fantastique méga fond des
quatre qui est là qui va tout nous
manger à chaque fois
mais on voit en tout cas il y a un
potentiel tactique dans la partie qui
est assez sympa il y a plein de choses à
voir
ça fait quelque chose quoi alors j'ai
peur que ce soit long mais
si tu
perds un peu du temps quand même H4
c'est moi qui c'est hyper tendu
peut-être qu'il faut bouffer mais quand
tu bouffonne le problème c'est que
maintenant tu t'en fous bah il est plus
la défense comme avant et maintenant
j'ai plus non plus tout refait une fois
que tu manges là voilà la jauge qui est
parti dans tous les sens dans les
catacombes
ça paraît super logique rien que pour
vous est-ce que le gain c'est pas tout
je m'en vais
[Rires]
non c'est pas ça mais c'est quoi
pas mal non moi j'ai vu ça bon je me
suis dit bon j'ai calculé un truc comme
ça j'ai dit bon d'ailleurs je sais même
pas vu que c'était malin j'avais vu tour
là cavalier
donc là en fait c'est bien noir
et pourquoi donc
il y a juste un point là en fait
et là on va avoir le bat que je voulais
bon sur ça
je pourrais je pourrais me moquer un peu
de toi et te faire
[Musique]
un jour quand même quand j'ai envie mais
ok il a fait 4 il a fait 4 donc
ça commence à peur pour aller raisin
avec toutes les lignes que tu montres
oui bon après
il est sauvé
et en vrai attends je vérifie maintenant
avec l'ordi ok il faut 4 seul link ne
perd pas évidemment ah oui oui c'est
pour ça que tu voyais autant de gars
noirs c'est parce que c'est
littéralement le seul coup qui perd pas
faute
bon du coup j'ai envie de manger
si je mange légitime alors on avait dit
quoi ça on avait dit que prendre l'un
mais pourquoi pas tout reprendre
la première ça me paraît plus logique
il faut qu'on défende la première ok
c'est vrai là je gagne la dame je crois
que c'est ça
tourbé 8 dans mes 8 ans
ça va pas aller parce que je dois avoir
ça
et je me lasse ça avec tout
et si tu manges ma tour je comptais te
faire
échecs sur la diagonale c'est assez ça
c'est marrant très méchant donc tu ne
peux pas jouer
[Musique]
ça perd un coup avec ton premier froid
il a joué tempo
il a pris un F6
encore une fois encore une fois seul
coup
et sur quoi F6 alors j'ai pensé à ça
mais ça marche pas du tout
c'est juste pour manger là il prend là
j'ai échec
je te mate et j'ai le mat que je voulais
parfait il est délicieux celui-là
mais non ça passe pas comme ça
et maintenant on récupère des
mois avec les noirs
[Musique]
faut faire un truc
ouais en plus
non mais en fait la pollution
oui
ok ok
une pièce moi je suis très je suis très
généreux avec les pièces des autres ah
oui
je vois ça
ok donc il a pris
bon il faut prendre de la dame
voilà
je vais voir en même temps je regarde un
peu un bouquet qui
a récupéré un pion mais
ça va faire annuler la niche
parce que ils font je pense si on fait
un
blocage sur sur la Casa qu'on avait tout
à l'heure je pense que c'est les fous de
couleur opposées de toute façon
c'est dommage qu'on n'a pas la même
scène tu sais qu'on a qu'on avait sur
l'Armageddon alors la queue pour la
table de Carlson
table à lui
où il bouge pas
tout le temps là et j'ai ça que pour sa
table tout le reste j'ai des multibord
mais qui relie pas branché je crois que
ça marche pas et du coup bah j'ai que
les j'ai rien à vous proposer que ce que
je vous montre là
une minute 3 minutes ah ouais non mais
là c'est la guerre là on peut pas tout
suivre
et après éventuellement on ira sur sur
google mais je trouve que ce format il
est vraiment très sympa parce que bah en
fait les joueurs vu le nombre de points
tu sais quand tu le barème quand tu
gagnes la partie en classique tu gagnes
3 points quand tu fais nul tu gagnes un
point chacun et il y a une Armageddon
qui va distribuer un demi point
supplémentaire au joueur et regarde la
force vraiment les joueurs pour le gars
regarde ce qu'il a fait charia il a pas
repris en F6 il a joué tout trois pour
me lasser des trucs sur F3 mais
maintenant j'ai juste envie de prendre
en D1 et je vais défendre la dernière
bah c'est ce que fait les raisins
surtout quand même point
et bah vite
ouais ouais
je commence à avoir des je sais pas on
va on verra la suite mais parce que je
me scanne Tour Eiffel
il y a même Dame des six là juste
mais ah ok ok
mais bon moi je peux récupérer là j'ai
un peu le jeu dans le but c'est jouer
bref
[Musique]
et découvert sur ça
je pense à ça aussi moi j'ai un tournoi
on apprend je pensais à ça pas là mais
qu'est-ce qu'on joue là sur wife7 c'est
hyper pendu là c'est tendu ouais ça
c'est cette tour clouée là c'est très
chiant
même des si ça marche pas il y a tout
refaire ça matte pour les Noirs ça c'est
compliqué je vois pas du tout ce qu'on
peut jouer à part ton géant
toutes les quatre étaient joués
maintenant Tour Eiffel tours
et on verra des fois avec MG3 ah oui
[Musique]
ok ah oui et puis j'ai pas non mais j'ai
pas j'ai pas tout refait à cause de tout
rêve de échec OK
bon je pense que ça va je vais je vais
gagner je vais faire ça
[Musique]
ils ont qu'une minute les deux joueurs
c'est terminé en fait c'est fini je
pense qu'il va essayer un de ces
couleurs F4
qui va venir j'ai un qui revient en
défense c'était l'idée de fout des
quatre aussi l'autre idée
donc non
[Musique]
attention à pas jouer tour DD2
même là ça marche OK
après un petit trajet pour voir des
échecs on est où
Ben il y a eu plein de résultats on a eu
on a eu
grosse victoire d'Abdou quand même qui
s'est pris une préparé qui s'y prime
contre prépa d'Ariane tarié il a piqué
la position jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que le
Norvégien craque il y a une nulle en
Armageddon et une nulle puis Armageddon
entre Carlsen et Wesley Sow où est-ce
que après un très très belle avantage
mais Carlsen qui s'est montré
intraitable en Armageddon il est trop
fort
et goûter schnak Amoura faut qu'on y
retourne parce que là les raisins ok il
arrive à l'emporter mais alors là goûter
chacun Moura c'est la guerre totale ce
qui paraît il y a plus de temps pour le
jeune
dernier coup avec une seconde à la
pendule
et je crois qu'il est je crois qu'il est
tombé
important et Nakamura
d'un point H3 et je crois qu'il est
tombé en chantant
et que
c'est 10 secondes je pense qu'il est
tombé c'est avéré faut vraiment qu'on
passe sur Naga
ouais c'est très chaud
allez attention
en fait parce que
je crois que a pris l'ascendant voilà le
jauge complètement c'est pas c'est quoi
on s'est arrêté un cavalière H3 je crois
des blancs rapidement on revient vite au
direct
il finit par perdre un peu tous ses
pions
de moins pour Google
Car de fou en plus sont très solides je
pense que Naka va gagner cette partie
c'est ouais
toutes ces pièces sont plus fortes dans
cette position
ça va après il lui reste il leur reste
10 secondes chacun là sur l'incrément
tout simplement tout le reste de la
partie
tout le reste de la partie c'est 10
secondes par coup maintenant c'est juste
un blitz les gens en plus continuent à
noter les coups alors normalement quand
tu es pas obligé il me semble c'est 30
secondes
à noter
que qui serait pas contre un échange de
dames
c'est chaud là plus de temps la pendule
il peut tout se passer
un blender d'un côté ou de l'autre ça
c'est important les pièces détendues à
chaque fois pour être sûr qu'il y a pas
tactique là on voit qu'il y a un visa
vilain attention
et ouais
c'était le attends ça a été raté c'était
quoi attends je vais mettre l'ordi parce
que là je je vois rien j'ai raté le coup
qui faisait avantage Google
c'est un raté apparemment ah ouais bah
c'est prêt après tour D8 ça m'attire
même pas c'est quoi la différence
c'est quoi la différence c'est
incompréhensible
il y avait quoi
pardon
on est dans le passé c'est trop tard
c'est un peu dur de revenir ça va
tellement vite là
et puis en plus la part de fou les pions
B2 là qui a l'air duraprise vous qui va
revenir à M6 je crois que le pion B2
puis en 4 va tout va tomber ça a l'air
juste perdu en fait pour Google je crois
je pense qu'il va abandonner le prochain
coup là
la paire de fou
quet
5 pour défendre son pion là
mais je fais ça en fait tu vas perdre
l'option
après la raison de jeu parce que ça
reste quand même du Bullet il y a eu ce
qui tombe quand même
comment est-ce que je peux terminer
c'est très bizarre ce format parce que
ça commence très lentement comme une
partie normale et ça finit dans un blitz
le plus échelet c'est clair c'est très
bizarre mais je trouve que c'est moi
j'aime bien et là c'est c'est à la fois
lent et rapide tu vois il commence
tranquille partie là puis à la fin bah
ça part en blitz et
et je trouve ça vraiment moi j'aime
beaucoup cette cadence franchement
il faut être sûr que la première opposée
elle soit à gagnante
ça doit être pas mal
après je peux aussi ne pas travailler ça
je peux aussi jouer et choisir ce que je
te mange en fait oui
et là B3
suivi d'un 4 et je pense juste à pousser
quoi échec roi bouge à 4 si on prend
et on va pousser le pion tomber avec la
paire de fou
des haricots pour le jeune goût cage qui
sait très très bien défendu qui a fait
une très belle game contre Nakamura il a
jamais
pour la nul ouais c'est clair
c'est juste perdu en fait
monstrueux cette partie là par rapport
alors que Guiri
ouais ça va être notre dernière partie
du jour ça va être sans doute
l'Armageddon entre Guiri et karwana
qui devrait être intéressant
voilà il y a deux qui zones en l'air là
peut-être on peut commencer par un fou
des trois
je pense qu'on peut simplement commencer
par fuiter 3 je veux pas te
contre-indication
encore plus simple à gagner je pense
de plus quand même
paire de fou et puis on passait trop dur
c'est le free bird
salut à toi
et là ça va peut-être l'heure du coup à
4 justement alors les blancs qu'est-ce
qu'ils font
il faut revenir avec ce cavaliers il
faut revenir vers
quelque part je sais pas
alors moi aussi en plus tu vois le roi
blanc il est pas si à cause des fous il
y a une barrière qui se fait ici avec le
avec la paire de fou contrôle absolument
tout c'est assez monstrueux ce qui a
fait cette paire de fou là
qui doit revenir pardon dans l'action
par H4 c'est pas terrible le fou car
cela
et le roi qui monte pour soutenir la
poussée de son pion
futur plan passé à la dame
par contre c'est un peu un cauchemar je
vois les joueurs qui continuent à noter
normalement la cadence quant à moins de
10 secondes à la fin quant à moins de 30
secondes à la pendule tu l'écoutes
il me semble que normalement avec des
ondes d'incrément tu n'es pas tenu de
noter des coups
et bon c'est chaud j'ai cassé
c'est un peu chaud quoi
[Musique]
déjà comme ça dans les tournois qui
gribouille
[Musique]
les compétitions par exemple la cadence
lente la plus courte c'est une heure et
10 secondes par couche
[Musique]
tu notes plus quand à moins de 5 minutes
ouais c'est ça dans cette cadence là tu
pues depuis noter à moins de 5 minutes
parce que tu as plus de temps
salut Guillaume dans le chat qui
représente Nantes
salut à toi
il prend son temps maintenant c'est bon
il a compris il a compris comment il
allait gagner ça
mais normalement le règlement dit que
avec moins de 5000 à la pendule
avec 10 secondes par coup et ben tu peux
arrêter de noter
tous ses coups aux échecs classiques
ne serait-ce que pour avoir des traces
des parties
et il envoie le contre jeu là il envoie
G4 mais c'est maintenant faut le tenir
ce purge 4 et comment tu fais
abandon sur fou aussi abandon il perd G4
ok bien sûr Marie ce soir il y a c'est
le bar la forge à Nantes club et Marie
la forge côté de la place Saint-Pierre
donc on va avoir maintenant alors si tu
veux ah ouais non non j'avais un poste
game
mais c'est un norvégien donc
[Musique]
tous ces trucs sont en général en
anglais
effectivement alors attention que ça ne
fasse pas rater le début de l'armée à
chaque fois ça prend environ 15 minutes
donc l'Armageddon de Annie Giri contre
erwana qui va se jouer très bientôt je
vais voir s'il est il est là mais les
joueurs sont pas du tout installés je
vais aller sur la scène de leur
la partie et voyez sur partie les gens
sont pas encore installés pendant ce
temps là je pense environ 10 minutes de
pause avant que les joueurs viennent
jouer leur Armageddon et ben je propose
d'aller voir
d'aller voir ensemble les interviews de
vachement parce que il a fait une partie
de ouf la préparation est très
intéressante donc je vous propose
d'aller voir
tout ça et
anglais je vous traduis à la fin ouais
alors je peux voir
et si tu veux mais aussi le le Magnus
post game
allez en anglais j'en ai deux
j'en ai deux en norvégien mais j'en ai
un en anglais
on se regarde ça
je vous les mets et là
21h30 diri carbonara
15 minutes pour pour faire ça donc on a
plein de trucs à voir à nous inquiétez
pas je vous ai réservé beaucoup beaucoup
de
post game on pourra le tout voir si vous
voulez alors
je vais aller sur la scène des
confessionnales
[Musique]
c'est no dire Beck la classe là alors il
a pas très bien compris l'ouverture
apparemment parce qu'il pensait qu'il
pensait être mieux et effectivement
après de la marche 4 comme on l'évoquait
tout à l'heure il a vu tempo il a vu
tempo la tactique gagnante pour son
adversaire
sans doute un peu et donc ouais il parle
très bien anglais effectivement ciel
bleu et
il dit c'est de la chance c'est grâce au
temps et voilà il s'en sort plutôt très
bien il est content de son coup
belle victoire pour lui je pense qu'il
faudra quand même qu'il repasse un peu
sur l'ouverture mais c'était bien géré
de sa part
j'en ai une autre si vous voulez je peux
vous montrer celle de 4 scène
après sa partie contre donc je pense que
la partie après aussi l'Armageddon je
pense je suis pas sûr il y a marqué de
poste game je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire post-games après la partie
classique ou après les deux parties d'un
magasin et de classiques ce sera la
surprise
[Musique]
le crack avec son humour habituel qui
nous dit que cette partie vit gagner sa
première partie gagnée de ce tournoi
long
c'est l'Armageddon donc elle est pas
forcément très bonne pour la confiance
parce qu'elle était un peu
up and down donc comme il dit et il a
dit surtout Dawn on a été surtout
moyenne et à la fin il a réussi à
rétablir l'équilibre et même à la gagner
donc il est assez content du résultat
final mais pas de la manière dont il a
procédé pour la partie lente en
elle-même il s'est trouvé
il a trouvé que ça posait un peu
meilleur à jouer mais pas au point de
rêver à la victoire ok ça marche si vous
voulez la dernière que je peux vous
montrer là maintenant c'est celle de
soetley alors so Wesley il a un peu
moins drôle mais on va quand même aller
le voir
et bah Wesley plutôt de bonne humeur
finalement la télé norvégienne qui a
tout donné pour lui faire dire que
Magnus était le meilleur joueur du et
elle y est parvenue puisqu'il a fini par
dire que c'était quand même pas mal de
se tenir ce genre de pause contre un des
meilleurs joueurs contre le meilleur
joueur stratégique de sa génération il
est déçu pour l'armée don il s'est dit
qu'il aurait peut-être pas jouer
exactement comme ça
contre un autre joueur que Magnus non ça
c'était pour la longue et dans
l'Armageddon il était déçu parce qu'il a
trop regardé sa pendule en fait il a eu
du mal à passer de l'état d'esprit parti
longue à l'état d'esprit Blitz et
résultat il a il a gaffé il aurait selon
lui prendre quatre plutôt que de prendre
la qualité prendre le pion de 4 quand il
en avait l'occasion et dès qu'il a raté
quelque chose mais avec nous c'est
rentré dans la pose et il a il a rien pu
faire mais effectivement les Norvégiens
sont très chauvins comme de le faire
marquer si elle est bleu
et on le serait aussi à leur place ils
ont le meilleur joueur du monde ah oui
non mais c'est clair un Magnus Magnus
c'est le meilleur joueur du monde et
peut-être même de tous les temps
donc là maintenant il est plus champion
du monde depuis maintenant quelques mois
parce qu'il ne s'est pas représenté n'a
pas voulu
continuer à faire les matchs
championnats du monde
mais après il reste présent il a encore
actif dans les tournois
il est ici donc il a fait hier il a fait
une défaite contre
[Musique]
erwana et aujourd'hui il a fait nul
contre so Meganium d'ailleurs je vais
vous montrer si vous voulez un petit peu
où on en est au niveau du score
d'aujourd'hui ah ouais important
alors vous voyez qu'un et demi contre un
c'est là qu'il a gagné l'Armageddon 3-0
pour à torov contre Ariana 3-0 pour Naga
annus guéri armage et donc à venir et
dernier c'est Ali resa qui fait refait
le sa défaite billard de Google pour
battre ma média et clairement leur
cadence là c'est pour nous faire des
parties décisives en long et ça marche
là on en a eu trois aujourd'hui et cette
cadence sans incrément avant le 40e coup
y est pour beaucoup je pense ouais
complètement complètement
et donc voilà est-ce que je vous montre
un petit peu aussi le standings
vous l'avez ici qui va être mettre un
jour voilà Hikaru 4 sur 6 avec Abdou qui
s'est refait d'hier qui a 4 sur 6 aussi
et ensuite et ben on a derrière on a Ali
resa pas bien au Kawana et gokesh à 3
sur 6
ans oui précisons que carwana ou guéri
vont avoir un demi point de plus tout à
l'heure un des deux car wanna ou guéri
c'est vrai carwana qui a trois qui
pourrait passer à trois et demi donc
troisième et guéri qui a un et demi qui
pourrait passer à deux
donc ça c'est les classements pour
l'instant
je n'ai pas encore vu en conférence de
presse
en tout cas moi si vous voulez on
m'envoie par message les toutes les
conférences de presse
qui ont lieu et je n'ai pour l'instant
rien reçu sur Ali resa donc on a
plusieurs qu'on n'a pas vu encore
à son habitude voilà
on l'a pas encore vu à niche je sais pas
forcément mais on l'a pas vu car c'est
dans la vue sont on l'a vu Google qu'on
l'a pas vu non plus car Roanne je sais
plus si on l'a vu hier je crois qu'on a
peut-être vu
et oui
Pizzi elle est Raisa a gagné on peut
peut-être regarder vite fait il nous
reste trois minutes avant l'Armageddon
regardez sa partie en accéléré
mais les raisins ouais allez en
attendant l'Armageddon entre entre
karwana et guéri
donc
c'est celle-là alors je vous la mets
je l'avais enlevé faut que je la
retrouve
elle est ici et vous la met en accéléré
elle était pas mal cette partie quand
même se présente tous les sens ouais
c'était vraiment excitant et je pense
que la cadence y était pour beaucoup
mais on a eu du beau spectacle le
gambida m'a accepté donc
c'est parti
de vente forest
faire je pense
moi
très critique il est très critique
envers la plupart des coups
et là tout d'un coup c'est devenu hyper
compliqué tactiquement ouais là il y
avait des sens il y en avait de partout
c'est un truc de fou
il a tout trouvé elle a tout trouvé et
là on pense qu'il est pas qu'il a perdu
autant et l'Armageddon a commencé et bah
super donc pile à l'heure boum boum boum
et on est là hop
alors c'est anus gris qui a des blancs
de nouveau
et qui doit gagner avec les Blancs
donc ça c'est une ouverture c'est une
ligne ah je pense à Jacky
je sais plus contre qui mais je me
souviens que j'avais un ami qui est
maître internationale qui était
complètement fan de cette partie du H3
c'est vraiment une idée
pointu je ne peux pas vous expliquer je
me souviens plus mais je sais que H3
c'était c'était
un nouveau coup et ben peut-être pour
mettre le roi H2 et mettre la tour en
géant comme il vient de le faire et
avoir des idées de taxes sur le roi noir
il me semble que c'est une partie qu'il
avait vu contre un chinois
[Musique]
E5 qui va être plutôt qui va être plutôt
Gucci je pense que si elle est bleu il
va nous dire H3 et guéri contre un
chinois
peut-être c'est pile ou face imagine
dragons
bon ok en fait quand elle est blanche ou
la Franquin
la pendule donc c'est chaud c'était pas
ça la question de qui c'était pour les
couleurs les couleurs ils gardent les
mêmes ils gardent les mêmes dans la
partie
tu fais à chaque fois sur les Noirs
enfin c'est pas juste quoi
donc c'est tu gardes toujours la couleur
que tu avais lors de la partie classique
et pour l'instant on a quasiment
toujours retrouver la même ouverture
dans l'armée donc dans la partie
classique sauf là là cette fois guéri a
changé radicalement alors rapidement
pour le format de l'Armageddon donc on
est en 7 minutes pour les Noirs contre
10 pour les blancs c'est du chaos
jusqu'au 40e coup en 40e coup on va
avoir une seconde parcours qui va se
rajouter pour les deux joueurs
il permet de pas finir trop trop en cas
haut ça va enfin ça va à la fin c'est du
n'importe quoi on a vu hier la partie de
Nakamura contre saw avec un saut qui
s'est levé qui continue
à jouer debout c'était assez drôle mais
ils avaient encore une seconde parcours
donc en fait c'était assez encore assez
correct
et ouais c'est vrai que ça évite les
gros flags
comme ça bon ouais c'est pas une partie
qui se termine au chaos en vrai
à ce niveau là déjà que sur Internet
c'est moche mais alors en vrai c'est le
meilleur
c'est atroce
qui pourrait être en prison donc
peut-être on va échanger une fois un
tour de 5 j'aime bien l'idée de contrôle
un petit peu la cinquième rangée tu vas
ramener l'autre tout ranger et peut-être
pourquoi pas essayer de taper sur la
colonne g et peut-être du h4h5 je suis
pas sûr à chaque page 5 je pense que le
pion quand même doit rester là pour
trouver les cases des fois aussi le roi
et le cavalier prend en cas de cavaliers
dans la position et c'est pour se faire
le pistolet d'allekine sur la colonne
j'ai avec les noirs
pour fermer la colonne
et F5 waouh
ce qui vient de trouver ici
notre ami
carvana tour et en plus ça attaque
cavalier qui va pouvoir me permettre de
pouvoir manger ce sac avec une pièce ah
c'est très malin c'est très malin
5 à suivre
ça fait peur quand même mais bon je veux
dire source j'ai moyen quand même de
défendre encore
attention prise F4 ouais c'est très
blanc mais la menace s'est prise
[Musique]
donc tu peux pas attendre tu peux pas
tu dois gagner
ok en vrai en vrai dommage 5 c'est un
coup hein
je continue ma petite quête option ouais
c'est vrai un moment donné tu as toutes
les personnes sur le roi mais moi aussi
tranquille il a pas envie il fait peur
des sacrifices peut-être
donc ok tu as plus de problème sur le
long terme et tu continues à menacer ça
donc
qui va arriver à sûrement
genre il prend du pion pour garder les
Damas c'est important parce qu'il
prennent la dame il y aura besoin pour
changer les dames et la finale avec les
tours sur une colonne fermée et pour son
mal placé ça se servira à rien de toute
façon la finale il s'en fout qui veut
pas gagner il veut pas faire nul pas
belle structure là il veut mater dans
cette position on a compris que le roi
il est ouvert tout ça et que la finale
nul apportera rien et il doit gagner
attention tour T3 aussi qui me menace
ok elle est cavaliers de cavaliers 3
cavaliers vient en H c'est très long
tout ça c'est très très long le format
là c'est Rama Guedon il y a eu deux
heures ko plus 10 secondes parcours en
partie classique et il y a eu match nul
entre Guiri et karwana et en cas
d'égalité ça fait Armageddon à suivre et
là c'est 10 minutes pour les blancs
contre 7 pour les Noirs les Blancs sont
obligés de gagner sinon bah ils perdent
leur magazon et
et voilà une seconde de rajout au 40e là
on est au 29 mais eux ils savent pas en
fait ils savent pas où ils en sont au
niveau des coûts donc ils savent pas à
quel moment ils ont ils ont une seconde
de rage en fait ça c'est sûr
ils peuvent pas compter les coups là
maintenant
la dame qui revient on a quasiment le
pistolet dans les kids ça j'en avais
parlé tout à l'heure
d'évaluation à détesté
pas mal hein il y a plein de trucs
les couleurs qu'ils avaient lors de la
partie classique ça évite de pas tout le
temps doubler tu vois
[Musique]
ça me paraît juste
le canon
ah moi je dis le flingue
j'ai pas E3 cavaler à 6 H3 mais j'ai H3
qui avait la saison
c'est ça peut être aussi team une
guerrière ciel bleu qu'on appelle qu'on
appelle la base
mais j'étais sûr que c'était guéri par
contre j'ai un qui rit chinois
je
peux me renseigner il faut juste que je
que je parle à mon ami Pierre Barbot
c'est un mec de chez moi et ouais c'est
un entier voilà là il y a la tour qui
revient harceler le le 4 c'est compliqué
pour guérir là qui peut pas faire son
plan H5
et que faire tu dis qu'elle va le 2
qui avait le deux
le joueur hollandais
est-ce qu'il y a des histoires avec
cavale dessin
Caval des 5 un coup acrobatique qui
attaqué la dame noire
mais il y a pas trop de casse de rebond
après pour ce pour ce cavalier
alors il me répond rien
un chinois incroyable j'attends sa
réponse
en fait il faudrait que tu vois et là on
attend le coup de de guéri qui
il sait pas quoi jouer est-ce qu'il faut
défendre F4 est-ce qu'il faut se ruer à
l'attaque est-ce qu'il faut sacrifier en
G6 évidemment non ça marche pas mais
est-ce qu'il faut le faire quand même
cavale des 5 me paraît le coup le plus
résistant
alors pour ces quatre ça a l'air dur dur
dur pour les blancs ici hein tu vas
tomber il attaque sur la clonage ça
allait trop lente en fait
trop trop lente
ouais bienvenue tu arrives juste pour le
dénouement et karwana est en train de
mettre une pression folle à guéri qui
rit vraiment qui suit beaucoup là
tu as vu
H3 Geri wangao
des fois j'ai une mémoire
genre je sais que c'est guéri et je sais
que c'est un chinois mais c'était c'est
pas
une mémoire qui se base sur les
nationalités des joueurs
bravo je trouve cette partie et enfin
celui qui m'avait parlé il m'a dit que
H3 c'était un cours émotionnaire je sais
pas quoi il adorait ce qu'il avait fait
et d'ailleurs il avait gagné une super
partie guérir c'est vrai que il avait
fait du beau travail et
c'est bon je l'ai
bah là il est en train de se faire
ouvrir
en direct et ça fait il a plus que 3
minutes il a rattrapé car wanna autant
et ça c'est pas bon signe il avait 3
minutes d'avance je rappelle au début de
cette partie
j'ai trois
il est F4
il est là il doit il doit laisser des
trucs
à Nice sauf que là c'est un peu la quête
un F3 dames 3 serpent des risques dans
un peu loin j'ai peur de prendre les 6
quand même un jour
attends j'ai laissé
ou attention si il prend il y a d'un
point H4
ça fait un peu peur
dans tous les sens mais je me sens ça
c'est encore mieux
je vais me dire
c'est terrible qu'il est en train de lui
faire la Fabiano
en fait c'est totalement perdu du parce
que là la tour bah elle est enfermée en
fait
et ça va tendre la main côté Aniche
rapidement je vais vous montrer
les résultats encore une fois on avait
vu tout à l'heure on va les revoir
encore une fois on voit pas bien le
Carvin qui a gagné l'Armageddon donc il
a un et demi
contre un et les le classement général
après deux parties et ben on a
maintenant
Caravana qui passe en tête avec quatre
et demi c'est vrai que il y avait un
demi point tu avais dit qu'il allait
être ajouté mais au final c'était un
point et demi qui s'est rajouté au final
parce que parce qu'il avait pas encore
ajouté les points il a gagné hier contre
Magnus
dans la partie la partie classique donc
karwana qui est premier tout seul avec
quatre et demi avec Naka et abusottorov
à 4 points à lire zaguet 3 points ainsi
que Anish Viry ouest les sauts 2 et demi
Carsen ma média Rohff 1 et demi et
Ariane tari avec un point sur 6 ouais
c'est pas mal ce barème là ça nous
permet de voir des résultats qui sont un
peu différents
deux sur 9 mais ça risque de faire un
une bataille intéressante qui va durer
longtemps et qui peut être serré jusqu'à
la dernière ronde c'est clair c'est
clair en tout cas moi j'aime beaucoup ce
format je trouve que c'est cool ça offre
des parties
intéressantes et on voit que dans toutes
les parties il y a quand même pas mal de
parties décisives ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et par rapport à d'autres
tournois qu'on a pu voir où il y a
beaucoup de nuls la cadence qui
s'accélère un petit peu et ben nous
propos c'est parti vraiment intéressante
d'ailleurs avec aussi le format et les
points système de points qui est calculé
c'est aussi hyper intéressant de voir
que les gens prennent des risques pour
marquer le plus de points possible donc
je trouve que c'est un format qui est
vraiment intéressant en tout cas et à
chaque ça marche bien
des parties spectaculaires
ça marche très bien et je pense alors on
peut peut-être avant de se quitter
parler de ce qu'on va avoir demain
tu as une infographie ou pas où je peux
non c'est pas
en fait demain il y aura Nakamura avec
les blancs entre Carlsen le classico il
y aura d'où ça torov face à sa fille
rouge jade donc les deux qu'on gagnait
aujourd'hui
Abdou ça te refaire le duel des jeunes
des jeunes espoirs
karwana avec les Blancs contre tari donc
coup dur pour ta rien qui se prend en
carwana en pleine bourre après avoir
perdu la partie importante d'aujourd'hui
ensuite on a ma média Rohff qui pas très
très bien dans ce tournoi il aura les
blancs contre goukesh donc les deux vont
essayer de se relancer après avoir perdu
aujourd'hui tous les deux
et enfin wesh les Soignies gris ou la
nulle sera signé vers le 17e coup
voilà
ok ben écoute super intéressant demain à
partir de 17h on sera encore ensemble
donc rond 3 voilà donc merci à tous
d'avoir suivi le stream et puis on va
partir avec un petit raid si vous voulez
avant de partir peut-être que j'aime
bien partir avec un raid à partir je
suis entre amis notre ami yosha
de notre part ouais plein de petits
bisous et puis moi je vous dis à demain
demain à partir de demain à partir de
17h on avait dit et merci encore à tous
d'avoir suivi le screen c'est hyper cool
et merci à tous bonne soirée à tous le
reste qui part dans quelques instants et
donc bonne soirée à tous portez vous
bien à bientôt ciao ciao salut à demain